mg il faut le dire mais je suis là
pourtant oui mais un présent mais ils se
disent on ne va pas avoir le numéro un
français en fait il vrai que tu stream
et que tu joues quoi je ne veux pas ils
ne veulent pas voir ses joueurs de
faible niveau c'est ça tu vois les cas
maintenant max ouais je vois les call
shop ou moins donc après on sera en
visio choix par un parent très fausse et
magnus response ou est ce qui va arriver
tu sais en redoutant dans sa chemise
comme une fois il s est fait risquer le
banda il est là il a pas de chemise
ouais pas mal taillé ces faits il s'est
fait l'essai s'est laissé pousser la
barbe
il a compris et il a compris d'ailleurs
je vous êtes tous tous les trois vous
êtes en vous avez le même style bobards
ouais un peu
parham qu'il a un peu raté non lui il a
un peu un peu plus se raser
non ça aurait été un peu mou un peu
moins parce que ici - mais oui raser
comme ça ouais mais il est sympa par
amel a tellement l'air gentil ce gars il
est très commun ça se voit en fait le
mec a vraiment l'air hyper cool adore je
connais pas le blog so de magnus très
important ça à magnus carlsen tout
bêtement
voilà à mais cet homme à moins de points
elo que toi 3047 c'est un peu faible
assez fébrile mais jai ho par aof
c'est par ama filet où elle 29 59 76
je le voyais beaucoup plus haut par am
je le voyais à 3050 personnes devaient y
être un moment mais il entonne alors
attends j'ai raté les adresse twitter
attentat raté l'année surtout jury
terrible ah non mais la tienne aussi
ben oui oui mais
la tienne est très rare à temps c'est la
grave
du coup avec le petit underscore c'est
ça et moi du coup gridstream ah ouais
j'ai raté j'ai raté et c'est corrigé
les scores carsen apparemment il faut
changer le type du stream aussi à le
titre en plus je les fais avant le
titularise vraiment me fera je me suis
pris le bug
le bug twitch quelle horreur
quelle horreur ça le titre pourtant je
sais que j'ai changé je les ai mis sur
youtube mais cette fois ça arrive
attends up
ça c'est ma hantise les titres à fallait
dire tu es le top bar voilà la question
que je pose c'est ce qui va avoir du
suspense non plus d'une heure et demie
de match ou pas ah ben on espère on
espère que on espère que l'écart ne sera
pas fait après les cinq plus un tu
penses
s'il tient si là encore adopté un point
ça peut encore jouer on va dire que
c'est ça pour les quarts sita genre à +4
c'est déjà fini tu dirais quoi ah bah
bien sûr non mais moi j'aimerais bien
que ce soit 50% après les 5 plus ainsi
un peu qu'ils aient un match donc en
gros on doit être pour parham au début
quoi pour leur foi à fond à fond pour le
suspense on à fond pour par alors que
par am je peux te dire qu'il a deux
caméras dont qu'il ait eu l'amère
allemand in derrière et magnus une seule
calmes
amnesty n'a pas lu les règlements non il
n'a qu'une seule calmes
ben c'est disqualification non c'est toi
qui as j'ai pas les règlements joueurs
mais si c'est écrit dans le règlement
alors c'est dans les way c'est dans les
règles du set up qui nous ont fait faire
enfin qui nous les ont envoyées la
veille quelque chose comme ça et du coup
en ce qui concerne les calmes qu'on a
fourni des caméras ou c'est toi cumul de
webcams gène me beau j'ai mis mon ordi
en fait
ok un deuxième mardi un deuxième ordi
qui de films par derrière
voilà important mais non magnus hui les
films et que par devant alors après
derrière il a le pablo de talent
panneaux publicitaires dont qui semble
ne rien pouvoir y avoir mais du coup on
voit pas l'écran de son ordinateur
c'est ça bah oui c'est l'idée c'est de
voir l'écran de l'ordinateur de leloup
enfin après honnêtement ça sert pas à
grand chose
non on est bien d'accord mais j'ai
l'impression que dans ses tournées sur
internet a quand même deux joueurs qui
peuvent enfreindre les règles un peu
comme ils ont envie c'est hikaru et
magnus bon alors là je sais pas si c'est
comme ils ont envie un médecin
honnêtement si je vais en france vers
elle encore une fois c'est comme j'ai
envie aussi un jeudi
oui oui mais enfin on voit qu'il y en a
deux qui le font et il ya tout le tous
les autres qui le font pas al oui oui je
veux dire dans ce sens là et frère après
c'est pas grave hein
mais bon là c'est juste pour dire que
alors après peut-être qu'il a une
autorisation quand on sait pas mais à
m'aimer mais les deux joueurs
oui c'est bizarre quand même qu'ils
aient enfin normalement il ya un devrait
y avoir une deuxième caméra ça c'est sûr
après alors je sais qu' une autorisation
spéciale
c'est si ta connexion n'est pas assez
stable pour avoir deux caméras ça
m'étonnerait que ce soit 4 tu peux avoir
une caméra qui filme offline et tu doit
la transmettre
donc à la fin du match cc c'est
peut-être une possibilité c'est
peut-être leur cible et donc sa part sur
une drague usine est ce que mathieu
cornette à illéla directement ragots dit
il écriteau crasse et l'autre jour par
am avec des problèmes de connexion est
d'ailleurs il n'a pas une bonne
connexion et pourtant il a mis les deux
cas mince et c'est quand même a souligné
mais ouais sicile géré par sylla pas la
connexion par contre ça va commencer à
faire beaucoup et dont amnesty jouer 3
alors je sais qu'il ya 3 qui est
possible un cahier f3 ça retombe dans
une preuve aussi à 4o ça c'est un marché
ça ça peut être qu'un petit pas c'est
impossible ça assez sexy un masque ou
alors vraiment c'est trop trop profond
trop évolué ouais c'est beaucoup trop
évolué non à la stat qui fait je sais
que tu peux pas avoir la cam pendant
qu'on le relâche village et je me suis
mis sur la kawa s'est clairement
mouillart et y'a pas un petit snort bref
haram qui sema mais bon ça c'est pas un
gars aussi grave enfin le gravissime
évidemment ça donne l'avantagé au noir
mais c'est pas fait quoi oui c'est pas
dramatique de toute façon annoncé n'a
qu'à qui allège le bon claude enfin lui
aussi dû tenter des bons clubs lateef
trop f2 et tout mais bon pour mes à
quatre c'est vraiment un mauvais coup
quoi c'est ça qui est beau est ce que tu
t'es pas soupçonnant en ce qui concerne
la gestion du temps de par am qui prend
quand même un beaucoup de temps un peu
comme yal sarine hier contre toi est-ce
que c'est pas une erreur format pour
l'instant c'est
matic peut-être pas une mauvaise
habitude a par contre j'aime pas trop ce
qu'il appelle des deux français 4 et b6
je pensais que tu pouvais justement
utiliser le fait que le pion à 4 pour
garder l'attention genre tu joues
cueille ses six têtes ou les pions
isolément une super agréable surtout
maintenant tu à la casse des quatre oui
j'aurais showcase et si cela je n'ai pas
neuve après il est très très très bien
et l'attaqué des caps qui menace déjà
relaté bien là dans la partie l'affairé
il a joué avec bliss a été clairement
pas moins bien il est même plutôt mieux
grâce à ce point 4 ans qui est vraiment
grotesque mais là déjà accéléré
déjà il a accéléré et je pensais
vraiment que c'était un épiphénomène 1
je veux dire c'était la première partie
du match
début de partie il a peut-être aussi
chercher un peu s'il va punir ou pas le
a4 immédiatement donc c'était pas un si
mauvais timing on va dire pour réfléchir
c'est pas comme mire la junte il ya une
position forcément facile à jouer
là maintenant ce serait bien que les
seuils de pas se contenter du minimum en
fait dans cette partie c'est là que ce
sera peut-être un peu difficile mais il
faut qu'ils essaient de la gagner
celle-là pour tout de suite marquer le
territoire - après un e à 4 encore une
fois c'est pas dramatique pour m'amuser
mais juste ça confère une position
facile jusqu'à la fin de la partie
parce que l'art est tout le temps cette
carte b4 en gros voilà c'est ça mais bon
après il s'organise et il va échanger
les fouilles et les tours en c1 il va
échanger les pièces petit à petit ça
doit quand même resté proche mais quand
on est gamin ça doit rester sur proches
bien sûr ladder avec les noirs comment
tu fais ce que tu veux presser
boss le problème de jauge et 5,4 c'est
que ce risque est quand même
stratégiquement travers des cases ouais
fou des quatre français trois c'est
quand même un peu artificiel je pense
pas que ça surtout que le fouquet's noir
après sera fort non mais j'aurais
peut-être essayer d'éviter les changes
des fous de cases blanches en fait
surtout ça c'est surtout ça qui me
chagrine un peu l'un d'ailleurs çà et là
il est en train de chercher à nouveau
s'il peut presser moi je vois pas trop
comment ça tu l'a finalement à il joue
et 5 très risqué après il peut pas être
moins bien mais mais bon ça ça va donner
des chances à magnus à un moment bah
ouais une fois qu elle peut en aucun cas
tu donnes quand même la casse des cas
d'un autre côté tu gagnes la case d3
owen non mais surtout bon alors
évidemment si peu je calcule 5
évidemment il est très bien mais ouais
c'est qu'un calque pas tenir si
rapidement ses preuves après le truc qui
est cool c'est qu'il a plus besoin d des
pions sur carte blanche pour contrer le
fou de cases blanches ont quelque part 5
il est bien oui mais [ __ ] bien sûr
autour d un bon en tout cas il y cherche
à faire le point la parent qui cherchent
à utiliser le mot slip ça c'est sûr mais
bon je suis pas certain qu'il y arrive
et puis mon n'aurait pas la perdre mon
prix d'entrée tu pense qu'il va gagner
beaucoup de parties dans le match par à
moussa où il va y avoir beaucoup de nuls
évitant les français n'ont ils pas en
guinée quelques il sait dans quel
secteur de jeu qui peut mettre magnus en
difficulté position compliquée tactique
ou
[Musique]
je pourrais pas dire exactement faut
qu'ils essayent de jouer à faut qu'ils
essayent de marginal de jeu plus
rapidement christine et ça va être une
grosse fessée probable enfin tu vois
quoi ils +8 plus 10 pour un magnus
au club on en espère un magic du
suspense donc on va espérer plus inclus
6 voilà en tout cas pour le moment il se
passe pas grand chose
la position doit vraiment être quasi
égal maintenant essayer de rentrer en b3
ou qua non c'est peut être un plan mais
bon il va rentrer en a six ou v5 de
l'autre côté et stewards n'aurait pas eu
quatre ici
kéhi des deux dames 6 bon après les au
minimum d'une c4
je montre un sur l échiquier risques et
b4 encore sur quel est des deux qui est
des trois bons revient il à fait prête à
me 6 quel est des deux ça peut
transposer après qu'un train d'ailleurs
si nous ne pouvait qu'être way pour mais
assez fou prend ses 3 et damas deux
wemmel moustier jockey ou quatre noms
mais en fait une menace plus vous prend
ces trois que damas devant ans et racing
pas mauvaise dans le sec 4 sur coup
franc il veut pouvoir reprendre de la
dame j'imagine ouais là on n'est pas
spécialement content de cet échange est
très noir il faudrait peut-être juste
prendre et partir avec roy y fit trois
sets 3-6 ouais
après si tu fais ça tu abandonnes tout
espoir légitime de garni d'un côté il a
admis demain à la pendule c'est
peut-être plus à tanger et génie des
tonnes ha
non j'avais une idée mais ça marche pas
je voulais prendre pendant ces trois
jokers 4 mais y'avait faut prendre 5
voir qu'est laleu-la de là le problème
pour pour par am c'est qu'il joue trop
lentement quoi enfin je me répète un
petit peu mais c'est le scénario d'hier
qui va se répéter pour lui ouais euh bah
après il ajoute c'est peut-être pas mal
jeu pour éviter au calcaire 3 mais même
si enfin je suis pas certain qu'il joue
au 4 mai c'est sans doute pas si mal
bon alors par contre faut qu'il joue
plus d'amendements s'assure à 27
secondes c'est pas une seule avec deux
secondes de rage ou je te dirai ça va
mais avec une seconde c'est chaud hein
ouais après la cij heureux aussi s'ils
veulent pas voir trop de ceci normal moi
qui commence par geci s'il veut pouvoir
bouger son cavalier puis joseph 5 sur
cahier des six par exemple après qu'ali
c3 russie soit après ces coûts sont
elles vraiment facile mais là faut
qu'ils se mettent en mode je ne fais pas
chier je fais nul et puis puis voilà oui
on verra la prochaine d'ailleurs petite
question dans le chatt intéressante est
ce que quand tu réfléchis à une position
dans ta tête et que tu calcules tu te
dis le nom des coûts ou pas c'est à dire
genre tu dis je vais jouer à fuzhou
quatre ils font un tabac oui bien sûr
parce que moi aussi je visualise mais je
me dis le nom des coups à chaque fois
beau et c'est une habitude que tu
prendre quand évidemment dit le nom des
coûts non mais c'était intéressant comme
question c'est intéressant magnus qui
réfléchit donc ils repèrent un peu de
temps il doit il doit d'essayer de
calculer une série de coups pour les
jouer rapidement après on ne demande
qu'à l'âge apparemment il doit voir la
vingtaine par amener un peu plus je sais
plus si les 98 ou 99 donc et des six
bon je t'annonce qui de la paire je
t'annonce des fêtes de parra maxime 2010
n importe quoi il a 20 ans s'il a 20 ans
il a été champion du monde juniors par
hama ouest a fait
je sais plus quand même et ouais en plus
il a le style pour il va pas la perdre
parce que tu sais déjà magnus n'a plus
qu'une minute et ton prochain coup ça
peut être caillé a simplement dans les
forêts qui va il faut qu'il accélère
quand même hein c'est à 6 après ce qui
est bien c'est que le roi blanc peut pas
pénétrer les cats ont prises puis
accueilli des cinq échecs
du coup comme n'y a pas de pénétration
possible voilà ça ça soulage parce qu'il
ça c'était sans gros problème le point 4
my mais ce qui m'inquiète c'est petit à
petit il avait 25 23 6-7 m'apprécient
les mauvaises conditions y avait pas d
ultime tentative de g5 h4 bientôt qui
peuvent arriver
je pense qu'il veut qui avait lieu cette
non la force car les primes à la casse
ouais ouais c'est un peu mieux ça quand
même enfin ces trois mille et une m6 et
g5
voilà bah il va peut-être pouvoir la
gagner à nouveau l'écart a lieu c'est
toi comme prévu donc cas doit être forcé
non salaire qu kg 6 sec et justice oui
il dit mieux si on prend ça s'est passé
ok bien jouer le petit aller-retour
voilà il répète j'aurais pas répéter il
a répété au moment où il commence à être
mieux mais bon après il avait plein à
temps mais jours à jour et doivent
s'appliquer aux cinq mois signe aux
rillettes jeudi qu'il ait beaucoup moi
je n'ai pas eu l'impression qu'il avait
un si la vie est un petit peu en ce
moment je crois en milieu de partie et
après on finit là d'dans la fin il était
bien quoi bon alors sicilienne nash
d'ordre de magnus
bon bah écoute alors voilà h3c des
lignes critique
alors oui c'est ça le niveau wang
championne sérieusement enrayée ça joue
bien ça fait fini ça fait qu ils
partirent et injustice c'est pourquoi je
connais pagis je suis le moment ça
j'aurais l'impression qu'ils peuvent
jouer fou et trois et que tu avais la
rendent fou 3 en est empêché carélie g4
et à et introduira sur six ouais ça n'a
pas trop de sens à shief 1,5 c ça
empêche de bouger c'est un quinze jours
ouais c'est ça mais le truc c'est que
les voleurs sont contents que j'ai
quatre ici pensez vous mais qui a
réalisé trois cavaliers cinq fois aussi
g4 puisse bouger 2 kg trop savoir père
était quasiment ta partie congrue tout
coup ils avaient forcé à faire à fils
pour revenir dans la vente au détail
ouais j'ai 3 enfin un people j'aime pas
parce que de toute façon agissent messi
parce que parfois acheté c'était un coup
est-il donc du coup je pense qu'il
fallait loger quatre pour pour jouer
là-dessus quoi ouais
bon ma news qui en tout cas ça
rapidement de la théorie par rame qui
est passé bien préparé pour son niveau
non aux abeilles boss 1 20 heures par
jour il a dit quoi il 18 18
c'est que c'est possible en réalité qui
travaille autant si j tapas au chaud
mais je rappelle que quand elle a
déclaré sage commenté attendre avec vlad
evans avait dit quoi il avait dit oui
mais si tu sais pas comment travailler
c'est parfois plus efficace de
travailler deux heures par jour que 18
pc intègre à quoi c'est beaucoup plus
travaillée vitesse de travail et
serrault j'adorais quand lé 18 heures
par jour c'est cette toile bien sûr
d'avoir suffisamment travaillé dans la
journée mais bon c'est quand il y en
avait demandé le nombre des chics et
avec des positions qui avait chez lui à
carqueiranne chefs d'état chez les
élites 3 est génial mais combien j'en ai
résolu 0 et voilà c'est le destin
mais ça fait marrer à chaque fois je
leur foi batlles
en plus il doit s'endetter à trouver
dans les positions aubin il les a et il
les a toutes une balle de position alors
s 4 ouais je sais que cette thématique
mais j'aime jamais school c'est quoi
comme plomb avec les noirs quand la
structure à la changer comme ça avec edc
poussé au sens j'aurais besoin que 4 de
base
oui ça dépend ici je verrais bien une
petite baie 5
comment as-tu coup tu commences à te
reprocher de l'ald amènera bidabé six
échecs en cas où oued et qu'il est si ce
temps le moment la question intéressant
de sandwichs vegan de paul mort fille de
jack and the machine a déjà sept balles
le pseudo ensuite comment il voit le
niveau des champions actuels par rapport
aux champions du pack de la résume pas
forcément on est plus fort mais
forcément on
de connaissance du meilleur matériel
forcément je veux dire je pense sans
caricaturer que si on met en mêle garry
kasparov avec ses connaissances de 1999
par exemple enfin quand il était plus ou
moins à son apogée où il gagnait tous
les temps moi ou la fed record et l'eau
il a dans un tournoi il a aucune chance
de gagner le tour il est mon ami il est
même très très mal
ouais après il peut s'adapter dans le
sens où il va jouer il va tenter de joe
des lignes 1 peut enfin sortir tout de
suite de la théorie mais c'est pas si
facile de sortir de la théorie
aujourd'hui du coup bay 5 a bien été
joués il changé et jusqu'où on peut pas
comparer les joueurs avec les
connaissances d'aujourd'hui ça n'a pas
de sens c'est parce qu'il ya des joueurs
qui s'adaptent plus ou moins bien à
l'arrivée des ordinateurs même si bon
alors après champions pas aux franges et
deux pions prend le set au minimum 9 6
il faut prendre cette dame décide d'un
premier set
ouais bon ça marche pas du tout en fait
oui mais non parce qu'après tu peugeot
qui ces trois rôles payant des 5
c'est ça peut être un avantage
stratégique pour les blancs et mais
juste de base je me suis ça gagne
peut-être une pièce parce que ça fait
une double attaque n'est en réalité non
way est en fait moi après tu peux aussi
commencer par l'un des six mais c'est
plus précis parce que tu évites l'aiea 5
intermédiaire en fait la ouache de
j'imagine et puis qui sait trop quel cas
et qui va arriver peut-être dante 5 même
t'échange les tables ou pas non pas pour
l'instant
donc tu est le problème si tu peux pas
choquer mais si si à tour prendre six ou
franchi ce qu'on attaque de l'autre côté
le fou sera plus protégé mais oui du
coup pour revenir la discussion de
comparer un niveau d
or historique est-ce qu'on va comparer
par exemple federer sampras borg
laurent gbagbo si déjà ils n'ont pas le
même matériel c'est pareil voilà les
mêmes raquette ils ont rien joyau qu'est
tamboise des malades à l'époque il est
impossible de mettre de la puissance
avec des raquettes en bois d'ailleurs il
en était pas vraiment de puissance et
plus d effet la fouer 3 par exemple
mais du coup par un qui commence très
bien ce match trop et là il a il n'a pas
de problème de temps de réflexion et
dans cette partie non non il ya une
bonne position
il sait qu'il a une bonne position il
sait qu'il peut mettre la pression donc
donc à partir de là c'est facile d'abord
halles c'est toi qui fais un petit
mouvement de pied maxime oui sur le
micro dont on entend on l'entend assez
fort des années je te préviens de
manière élégante
j'ai les pieds qui bouge tout le temps
ouais c'est quand tu es concentré que tu
réfléchis vite non voilà donc wait haram
qui fait le début de match qu'il avait
besoin de faire et on va voir si c'est
réussi à conclure ce serait bien qu'ils
qui concrétise cette petite occasion
qu'ils étaient cinq
ouais alors j'aurai commencé torfou 3
pascal hayatou français 2
j'ai envie de poser la question est ce
que ton française d'armes français de
dames bas c'est nettement mieux pour les
blancs mais du coup tu peux commencer
parfois étroits et c'est encore mieux
c'était encore plus sûrs d'être mieux
oui ça y est c'est 3eme y consent menacé
dé foot voilà ouais tu as franchi ou la
c5
qu'est ce qui se passe qui insiste pour
points 6 fou prend 1,6 je pense qu un
tour des 5 à la fin non non il ya des
objets 4 il a peut être raté je pense
pas qu'il ait raté
on va voir tout de suite à la can heil
est pas content il est pas content
et en prime six jouets puis on prend
fois ci c'est donc comme dit la dame eux
quatre ils adorent le 4-1 fou prend 1,6
ouais d'accord donc sur tour des cinq
hilario red army j'ai quatre dames le g7
matt donc sur vous prend ainsi s'il veut
dames 4 empêche dame g4 qui prêtent à
thème cheikh abdallah m 5 pieds qui est
possible pour pour par sommes donc dame
j'ai quatre échecs qui aurait roy a
fuité dame f5 qui couvrirait beaucoup de
cases pas juste à une vitesse
impressionnante et mais après du coup
sûr roger c'est peut-être obligé
fermiers le plan sérieux je suis d'avis
et 5 mois et aurait pas un jour de fou
leroy j'essaie de pardon ne m'étonnerait
pas un joueur de foot roi puis tour f
mais peut-être faire pour ces six tours
décisifs on va voir parham qui arrive
voir si j'ai mal autant il va prendre
il va prendre la nuit je pense il a joué
il n'a pas le temps là déjà il a trouvé
dans le g4 2005 c'est pas mal at en
sueur froide g7 est ce que t'as pas tout
un je voulais essayer de passer par le
côté mais tu peux pas non c'était 3 3
autant je vais [ __ ] ouais non mais de
bastia oui tu peux voir arriver angers 4
en fait tu peux pas
et j'imagine qu'à pas de fous prochain
calcul ça fait que perpète ouest par
personne dams et 8
je sais suspens
il faut bon tennis
non la c3 bien joué ouais il joue comme
ça mais ça me semble un peu sustème et
au port il va rentrer sur la deuxième
avec la tour je ne peux pas et elle
prête à 17 tu que je te trompes des
huîtres est d'accord donc tu vas faire
quoi et afu g5 fouet cette la tour des
deux échecs pardon j'ai déjà joué pour
gagner en réalité après je suis pas sûr
je pense pas qu'ils soient mieux pour
l'instant ouais mais trois secondes
ouais mais c'est facile là pour le coup
tu as découvre vraiment facile
maintenant avec les blancs tu vas mettre
franges et 5
tu as joué droit je crois au g4 la
guerre sainte croix ça c'est un autre
problème
tu vas être l'orangé qu'as tu à refaire
des échecs à qui prend un mais trois
ouais
si l'acte pas il la perdra pas celle là
non ça tu peux pas perdre au g4 que
juste pas perdre le même gagner plus
avec les blancs chautemps rock assez
bien joué ça surprend en deux nuls va
pas aller jouer le lag hockey par contre
va falloir résoudre ses problèmes de
connexion sinon c'est déjà dur de jeu
quand magnus après a pris fin
franchement je voyais moi je te voyais
un peu moins fort parham après la
différence se fait souvent après une
heure une heure une heure et quart de
jeu là il ya une période difficile
bon là il n'a pas mis ce qui toutefois
s'il a bien joué à trois comme comme il
faut résister qui devrait atteindre sa
deuxième caméra
c'est vrai que malgré ces coffrets de
connexion il a fait l'effort de mettre
les deux caméras et c'est tout à son
honneur
ouais il y aura peut-être du une caméra
au fun ça aurait été mieux pour lui même
mais il n'a pas voulu s'embêter
peut-être bon après deux façons il sait
que malheureusement sur internet s'ils
venaient à créer l'exploit et abattent
magnus c'est un peu ça aussi le problème
de serre et de ces compétitions sur
internet c'est qui va tout de suite être
suspecté quoi c'est chiant ça et dans
une baie quête de même glissé sa prépa
en fait tu connais non pas spécialement
mais après je connais des positions
similaires déjà les campings en fait où
tu joues de trois fuites b3 donc avec
les pions rade et v3 plutôt 4 avait
quatre c'est déjà parfois c'est
désagréable pour les noirs ça là je
trouve que parra mais trop passive dans
sa conception
ouais c'est 5 auquel parce qu'il veut
éviter de dépenser quelques baies 5 à 5
donc c'est pour sa c5 et là il faudrait
pouvoir choquer le cap sinon tu t'es sûr
d'être moins bien sita paquet 4.5 ça
marche pas ici
il faut je pour payer le 4 f 5 puis fois
ici c'est un truc du genre
mais j'ai peur que ça suffise pas pour
dans cette position parce que le
problème c'est que t'as plus et b6 à 5
et blanc ont complètement déployé leurs
airs de l'âme quoi mettre la pression là
bas oui dans le chatt seul cornetto peut
connaître la prépa il faut trois caméras
pour être sûrement être trois caméras de
télé pas sûr du tout il faut une caméra
dans les oreilles parce qu'il faudrait
vraiment c'est un arbitre un surtout oui
bien sûr j'arrive pas à comprendre
comment ça on a on y arrive par un perso
ça ça m'étonne ça m'étonne à chaque fois
parce que ça ça et ça y arrive jamais
quoi briller réfléchi en tout cas pas
ramer il doit sentir que c'est mal parti
la mairie qui avait eu 4 semble être le
coin c'est assez logique sinon tu es
enfermé deux façons ouais bon après tu
es comment bien que 4 ou t3f 5 kgs de
thé quand même bien oui mais au moins tu
te déploie et tu sortais pièce que s'ils
n'ont pas assez en fait s'ils jouent pas
eu 5 tu ton fois nous narre il va rester
en série toute la partie 1 ouais c'est
ça sinon tu joues ta le c7 pour jouer le
5 mai à bâle mais que tu arrive
peut-être pour le coup après faut pas
voir tous mes 6 juin dame ces deux il y
aura pas de découvertes lors eu cinq
crises crise prises prison encore tout
est encore après la witch le ramener en
criant des 4 et où tu seras peut-être un
peu mieux mais c'est pas dramatique
après peut-être que hyundai ici avec les
blancs contrôler la case avec le fou
puis après tout à la casse g3 qui est
pas mal pour son cavalier
bon il joue au foot détroit à ce 5 tempo
normalement ah ouais là sinon
c'est mieux d'abandonner si c'est pour
pas joué cinq saisons pas pas le choix
il prend il prend il prend trop de temps
là il prend trop de temps par à mûrir
fait la même erreur que sarine hier
quand même ouais mais il n'avait pas sa
position en sinon il prend va pas aussi
autant de temps c'est que l'on observé
et c'est comme ça réveille à il ne met
pas ses positions dans l'espagnol
enrique où il prenait beaucoup de temps
bon mais là ça va plus ou moins quand
même non baho - mais au moins tu perds
pas tout de suite mais bon après itunes
app et ça peut vite dégénérer parce que
peut-être le plan de manu ça va être la
passion de jockey eux deux et au moment
opportun grand roque et puis pousser
tous les points a droit et mater sans
compter que la dame peut se faire en
faire tellement n'ont pas raison en fait
c'est qu'à ta tête gens vers un cavalier
ou quatre ici ouais mais keyyo 4 f3 à la
fois chic kg calcémie trois là il menace
rien du coup km5 pas grave le purge 7,7
présage cette prise le 5 mai où au moins
tu rentres dans l'arsenal et tu feras b
6 à 5 tu contre attaques de l'autre côté
tu vas peut-être tiré là nul là dedans
moi pas sûr même tu peux essayer ou
alors tu jour où m6 à mes attentes soit
si certains tirent tous prochaine qui
mena study qui a pas de menace mais
france est d'apprendre à me prendre un
point et puis on prend g4 échec à la fin
on l'est cette confiance au duo pop
ah non tu fasses confiance puis surtout
pas surtout pas la grosse erreur grosse
erreur berman des coups comme cavalier
f4 peuvent menacer en premier aux aveux
oui non noté non car il y avait cinq
cavaliers 5 c'est vraiment obligé on va
voir ce qu'il fait mais c'est pas bon
signe parce qu'apparemment les deux
premières on a aidé il est bien rentré
dans son match là il se prend un
[Musique]
il se prend une cartouche fait le truc
c'est que ça peut aller très très vite
après ouais s'il commence à lâcher est
pas là ce sera pas grave mais s'il en
perd 2 ou 3 après ça peut oui on peut
finir à plus 15 ou plus 20 quoi ça peut
vraiment être insupportable c'est ça au
nom showcase tranquille domaine pions
pas assez fort par âme ouais tu peux pas
voir trop mené 2 - après 15 trous non
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
c'est n'importe quoi
ouais donc aller lâche très bien soudée
6 à un moment peut-être qui a été quatre
d'abord est fou des six ensuite c'est
dur quand même
je comprends que ça lui plaise pas mais
bon un moment faut vous rendre une
décision quoi voilà tu prends une fois
en d6 fait tourbe et 8 et je suis pas
toutes actives 1 à trouver tu peux pas
être le tour c'est huit ans piller un
péché est-ce que tu t'en tapes à 5
bon du coup moi bah maintenant à 58
sultan plus du tout puisque rapion prend
et bessette
c'est une catastrophe
ça c'est le point ça il aurait gagné
garder un peu de temps tu as des singles
c'est un b 5e j'aime bien il va avoir à
du coup d'avoir d'avoir lâché d'avoir
lâché 3 minutes sur rien du tout en fait
ouais c'est ça non c'est pas rien du
tout il a une position de mauvaises
c'est pour cette île a lâché 3 minutes
mais un moment ouais faut être plus près
du métier quoi en une décision ça c'est
un truc que toi tu fais très bien
d'ailleurs
ouais souvent c'est un des points forts
bah c'est parce que je m'en fous d'avoir
une position de marque c'est ça qui
arrive va d'ailleurs ma milliard j'en ai
quelques unes des positions on va dire
catastrophiques douteuses douteuses mais
c'est vrai que tu l'aies vous bien ce
position as tu réussi à tenter les
pillages arrête la pression c'est un des
gros points forts un ah oui c'est sûr
[Musique]
bah j'en ai retourné quelques
quelques-uns mois puis tu retournes même
les joueurs du top niveau
au lycée ça agile en rappel d'une partie
contre vichy où je me faisais mattel
partout puis moreau a failli et s'est
dit aventure chez plus jusqu'en g4 avec
leurs robes noires et j'ai gagné cette
partie barham qui a été déconnecté qui a
été reconnecté et magnus a été fair play
je crois qu'il a attendu qu'ils se
reconnecte pour jouer à magnus sa part
confère la connexion ne tient pas perdu
mais bon il a vraiment tout contre lui
je pense qu'il a le même problème que
les chinois avec les vpn parce qu'il a
il hilare cliquer sur un truc en fait ça
se voit et qui cliquaient sur quelque
chose sur son ordi way a été suivie
faire ça c'est l'enfer s y aller en
train de galérer à toucher son modem
sais pas quoi
c'est l'enfer ouais ça c'est un des gros
problèmes
c'est aussi pour ça que mon les
compétitions online c'est pas vous
allécher avec mais tu peux fins si tu
peux pas faire jouer des participants
dans les mêmes conditions
oui ça va pas honnêtement c'est hyper
frustrant pour de commenter après les
matches comme ça en fait ouais sur mon
grand tu es aux us que tu as 10
millisecondes de ping c'est pas pareil
que bon moment comme tu es en chine que
tu dois composer avec l'interdition mme
lauria mathieu qui entraîne une chose
iranienne qui disent on vraiment des
connections skype avec sa race a fait
planter je dois appeler sur téléphone
défend la connexion est meilleur quand
ils vont au siège de la fédé à l'aller
chez lui clairement
c'est frustrant c'est frustrant parce
que du coup et le match d'un soupçon
d'intérêt vous le début du match vu
qu'ils jouaient plutôt pas mal mais s'il
doit se soucier si russie le problème de
la connexion s'est même pas uniquement
sur l'échiquier
enfin ou sur la pendule c'est aussi bon
bah c'est décourageant ça prend des
forces de devoir de la charge mentale de
devoir penser à sa connexion et puis ça
déconne mais que c'est super frustrant
et c'est donc en plus c'est sa perle
super de l'influx nerveux tu perds de la
motivation
tu perds tout quoi ouais bah non c'est
c'est un problème est là encore un an
tous les toits que je commente il ya
toujours plusieurs joueurs qui ont des
problèmes de connexion c'est même pas un
joueur maintenant
ouais c'est plusieurs joueurs marais
parce que les joueurs doivent avoir 36
caméras
plutôt qu'un arbitre ouais puis après
c'est normal d'avoir une caméra ou tu
montes à tête et sert à ça permet
d'avoir des flux vidéo ça évidemment
c'est normal mais bon qu'est ce qu'on a
besoin de la deuxième caméra surtout
déjà parent a débattu de cette deuxième
caméra
elle prouve rien quoi vraiment ça n a
aucun intérêt alors après ça c'était la
grande idée de notre ami un streamer
américain mais mais on voit on comprend
pas vraiment ce que ça à ce que ça vient
prouver quoi et c'est vrai que là je
suis pas sur la voie la cam 1 sa
deuxième cape qui rajoute mais pour en
recueillir la position du coup j'ai cinq
qui sans doute après faut voir h6 vous
prend un f6 et ensuite celle investie
spa sur dame prend peut-être grande et 5
par exemple c'est sympa visuellement
pour les noirs c't'histoire main basse à
des pannes successives ou g5 marche les
plans peuvent être plus sinon c'est
légal donc ouais mais en fait oui enfin
on ne peut pas on peut pas empêcher la
triche online 101 arbitres présents sur
place c'est impossible c'est
complètement impossible avec un arbitre
par contre je pense que c'est c'est
c'est faisable après ouais après faut
faire attention parce que les tas sans
doute pas mal de trucs genre voyait
qu'ils sont assez indétectable eto'o
mais oui donc là qu'il prend 1,4
normalement c'est mon argument tour de
l'arbitré à la maison c'est que déjà tu
fais si un gars veut tricher il prend un
risque en fait parce que là à l'heure
actuelle aucun risque mais là tu fais au
moins à minima même si t'es pas sûr
qu'il chope le gars oui enfin un vrai
risque quoi il peut vraiment serré ça
oui est-ce qu'on peut tenter un pion
prend effet par exemple tu peux avoir
entre lima des pas des fausses triche
n'est tu vois mon 6e
s'il arbitres par exemple tu vois il lui
fait passer de détecteurs de métaux il
le jure un téléphone dans ses poches
mais on peut
ok je la veille sur moi et cette rage de
messi l'a par contre s'ils découvrent
une oreillette invisible dans l'oreille
là c'est un futur de justifier prix mais
bien sûr tu peux pas dire c'est par
accident
non tu prends tu prends un vrai tu
prends un vrai risque quoi alors que là
à l'heure actuelle c'était une
oreillette invisible tu prend absolument
aucun risque et ça c'est un problème ça
c'est un problème insoluble tant qu'il
ya des arbitres présents ça c'est sûr
c'est un vrai problème fait confiance
oui c'est bien sympa moi j'ai je dois
montrer je dois montrer ma pièce et tous
m'ont super ça pour un cabanon ça ça
peut vraiment rien en réalité
bon après la plupart des joueurs sont
clean arcachon sète alès et pas de
soucis mais mais ses tentacules et la
plupart des joueurs sont ils que tu peux
saint-jude ya à oui non ces tâches et
sion on voit bien dans d'autres sports
par exemple aux cyclistes dans un moment
il n'est pas qu alors là je sais pas
trop s'il en a actuellement mais il
n'est pas de l'exception c'était les
coureurs crime
aujourd'hui je sais pas du tout comment
ouais
comment ça marche à kembo c'est un des
sports les plus contrôlées du monde
maintenant donc oui tabac ça bien sûr je
veux dire c'est enfin je parle du
cycliste pas ce que c'est c'est le sport
et ses engagements c'est le store
référence mais je suis le premier à les
défendre en disant que vous déjà ce
qu'on leur demande de faire c'est quand
même assez fou en termes de courses
d'efforts donc là je pense que ma news
dojo dame a fuité tour 8 6 mois il est
moins bien c'est mon as quand même de
rentrer en vain et de jouer les cases
noires et par homme qui à nouveau pas
trop mal autant donc voilà winants mais
à chaud il ya mille façons de tricher
sans arbitres présents oui c'est pas la
peine de vous énumérer
tu peux tu peux en trouver en trouver en
retrouver après l'intéressant c'est
comment tu fais quand il ya un arbitre à
la ce serait une vraie question pour la
peine
mais oui dans le cyclisme ils sont très
contrôlés aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que c'est un sport qu'on va
plus regarder si jamais rien n'avait été
fait en réalité le sport serait mort je
pense juste ouais
après oui c'est vrai que c'est dur de
les mettre toujours enfin de les pointer
du doigt alors que bon en athlé en
natation enfin de partout c'est aussi
très suspect et puis au fond de teint au
foot
la place maintient foot oui mais bon
après c'est aussi la stratégie de on
attrape personne n'y a pas de problème
mais bon oui mon position agréable pour
parra - finalement qui joue les cases
noires devant le roi qui est nouveau un
peu mieux il fait quand même son match
très bien qu'il en gagne une peut-être
pour se débloquer ah oui moi ce serait
très bien en plus manqué crise voilà il
est pas mal bon après c'est pas
forcément suffisant pour l'instant
dans l'état actuel est ce qu'on peut
faire un truc que madame si si si si mon
idée c'est sûr dame bessette d'avoir
tour et 8 échecs peut-être non mais bien
sûr qu'il ya toujours de la triche en si
triste mais bon alors peut-être cette
année un peu moi au tour de france mais
les années précédentes quand même les
les perf était plus crédit déjà ce qui
fait plaisir
cette année c'est avec le niveau
crédibilité ça ouais top après c'est
possible c'est toujours le même problème
oui mais ils sont cons retombe sur des
pertes ou au jeudi qu'il y en a
forcément quelques-uns qui sont dopés
c'est sûr ouais alors après c'est
peut-être plus du dopage mécanique que
ouais que physique pour la peine
oui moi alors ça oui c'est encore un
autre problème mais ouais je veux dire
c'est de la triche dans tous les cas
après oui oui je veux dire juste que les
en fait en contrôlant plus ils ont forcé
aussi les resquilleurs à évoluer dans
leur manière de faire et pour la peine
si tu te fais choper la preuve elle est
vraiment
réfutable l'insultant et choper avec un
moteur dans le vélo très très très mal
oui c'est un peu la même histoire que
les arbitres dans les salles c'est que
le jour où tu te fais dans l'est dans
les pièces et au moins si tu te fais
choper tu prends vraiment très cher oui
et ça c'est un bas de toute façon ça
c'est le seul le oui c'est un point très
important c'est à dire que si si magnus
si moi aussi hikaru 6 caruana enfin bon
peu importe qui si elle nous se fait un
jour choper en train de tricher
bah c'est pas de la f1 alors ce sera pas
bad life mais dans les faits tu joues
plus aucun tournoi tu es plus jamais
invité à un tournoi de haut niveau oui
n'en existe plus quoi entre guy mois là
c'est ban 5 ans + shadowbane life
voilà oui jadot panne qui fait très mal
à shadow banking chavanne fait très mal
mais oui oui tu donc tu vas tu force à
prendre un gros risque et donc le risque
va pas être pris quoi on voit là
normalement sur la même chose bon du
coup il va la défendre notre magnus ou
pas là il est mal de temps mais alors là
il faut voir sur ton des signataires to
run with me demander cette antenne web
six tours prend il y aura pas tant
france et trois fois ci ce dont tu vas
devoir faire rager 7 et la france et
cette annonce je prends ce septième bout
des six balles en 2004 mais 400 bébés
katia pâtes ont pensé troyat fou ou 5 et
tu vas gagner un pion mais est ce que tu
vas l'agoa 4 à 4 un cadre plus précis et
sur pions prend comprend et tour c'est 4
fois 5 et tour français 7 mai après
peut-être que le roi arrive trop vite
allèles dame je sais pas donc d4 et
jouer truc c'est qu'il se fixe sur noir
là c'est ça le problème d'image hisser
sa vraie annoncé cette info et fils à la
fin terrible ça peut être moins bien en
plus parce que c'est les pions sur noir
il peut se prendre un fou ou un fou qui
arrive tu à te faire [ __ ] cinq échecs
intermédiaire du coup m6 voici sur fos
un riff wef six étapes a le temps et de
prendre vraiment sale elle peut être
chiante à défendre
non ouais trois systèmes corp oui j'ai
pas les faire faute s'il ya un problème
il a croqué où il a complètement craqué
à akwa qu attend maintenant f k parce
que ça déjà f4 et puis même tu peux
celle d'aubagne le fou genre tu joues
food et 6 fautes roche aurait jeu ça et
surtout prend 1,30 à plus de cauet fait
noir tu vois surtout b2 tu te prends au
c2 alors que là il est en train d'être
fixé sur noir il va parler gagner ça n'a
aucune chance
ça c'est nul mais c'est bizarre et
magnus tiare au t4 ouais mais plus rien
toujours rien mais bon tu sais moi je
rappe sur trois 1,4 il tentera la gagnes
tu connais bah oui safina le fou de même
couleur comme ça il n'y a rien à faire
mais après il ya des trucs ou et qui
sent bizarre pour revenir au score
c'est par exemple en fait pas déjà
moi ce qui m'énerve le plus c'est d
autorisation thérapeutique parce que ok
alors des des sportifs peuvent être
pénalisés parce qu'ils sont ils sont
asthmatiques par exemple mais enfin si
tu veux le par là pourquoi tu récompense
quelqu'un qui a naturellement 20 ans il
ya un problème
oui je commence je veux dire tu vas pas
aider quelqu'un à résoudre un problème
artificiel artificiellement
alors que bon moi je peux dire c'est un
juge d'une vo2 max sur cette part dira
90e peut-être moins sans rien manger
j'ai jamais fait de test mais pourquoi
j'ai moi je sais pas le droit d'avoir
une idée au dommage ça 98 oui oui je
comprends ce que tu veux dire c'est que
si voix la tête aident à régler un
problème physique avec des produits
chimiques
voilà ouais entre guillemets et donc du
coup tu donnes un avantage
puis c'est la porte ouverte à tous les
abus parce que oui quand c'était froome
qui s'était fait choper est clairement
s'ils avaient faim chez plus cher
puisqu'il en était parce que j'aime et
je crois que ce que j'avais suivi au
début c'est s'il s'était effectivement
dus à la ventoline c'est qu'ils en
auraient pris au moins quinze 15 bouffer
quoi mais ce qui est énorme
voilà et du coup le plus probable
c'était une injection de ventoline par
suppositoire un truc du genre enfin
c'est ce que j'ai nagé pas important par
suppositoire la pointe est importante
ouais au moins t'es pas gagner en parts
ou quand même c'est embêtant quand je
suis là ils sont partis là lundi aux
deux mc sacré tranquille c'est le
marathon en moins de deux heures non je
crois pas tant il me semble que les
meilleurs en début de match incroyable
petite question at il déjà eu des tops
joueurs mondiaux qui avec l'arrivée de
l'ordinateur n'ont pas réussi à
s'adapter et sont devenus des joueurs
moyens ça par rapport à l'arrivée
d'alpha 0 par exemple est-ce qu'il ya
déjà des joueurs du top qui du coup on
ont pas réussi d'après toi bien faire le
l'adaptation la datation à quoi aux
ordres aux oreilles 0 on va dire ah bon
on va pas dans l'élite dans l'élite ça
va obliger impression que tout le monde
sait y en a qui sont adaptées peut-être
pas une invasion ou 90 s est incroyable
et j'ai peut-être confondu
winants 90 euros c'est fort je suis en
plus donc là ça a l'air sympa pour
magnus non tu vas pouvoir avoir un jour
des pions français 5 c 4 et faire
rayonner tfou des américains owen tu as
raison mais oui je connais pas bien les
chiffres enfin toujours est il que j'ai
pas 90 de vo2max du coup ça pourrait
aider ça pourrait aider et dans les
échecs il ya du dopage a déjà entendu
parler de dopage à base à base de deux
cachets de une fois mais après on n'a
pas de nom j'ai jamais entendu parler
d'un contrôle antidopage positif j'ai
entendu des rumeurs sur un joueur mais
ben laden a eu à prendre un impôt
positif une fois le flatter un contrôle
positif et tout fait c'est ça ouais
ouais terrible pour un problème à ce
même problème d'allergie
ce qui fait d oedème de quincke donc
c'est dangereux il peut mourir
vraiment donc dès que ça arrive ça il
fait il se fait une piqûre sauf que il
était dans un tour elles n'avaient pas
l'ordonnancé il a eu un contrôle
antidopage le lendemain ouais mais bon
après ça tu peux donner l'ordonnancé 3
pts ils savent c'est ce qu'il a dû
fermer de base oui j'ai pas bien oui
mais comme enfin comme on peut justifier
la prise du médicament ça va oui c'est
ce qu'il a dû fermer t'es pas bien ah
oui bien sûr je dois justifier
oui je la justifier bon ça c'est moi
j'aime pas du tout pour les noirs genre
de truc mais après le toit pour toi
j'aime pas avoir les fous comme ça sur
le roi ça me saoule motion que ça ouais
t'as bien plus mais je peux leur prendre
déjà si j'ai envie au cas où
mais si tu leur prends ton tout bétonner
plus le même tu n'es plus rayonnant et
en vacances et si je fais un cavalier f5
ici voilà sur moi alors seconde jouer
son bac il ya cinq dames des cinq mètres
les pièces un peu bougé pièces et du
gpac y avait des cats que tu as maté
enjeux de ces terribles baget de faire
le maso motte
ouais m'attend j'ai 2 ouais non ok dame
d'etchemin que ça fait mal c'est pour ça
que magnus ce même à l'otan elle serait
bien d'une petite victoire de par
hamelin
ah bah oui non mais il fallait plutôt un
bon match chez lui il a eu une partie
catastrophique
d'ailleurs il a changé assure à preuve
la france et 3 sans se poser de
questions oui oui là il a il a accéléré
il a accéléré
c'est une de ses qualités d'ailleurs par
main de manière générale il joue assez
vite mon alors après je me dis rania
l'eau s'ils jouent plutôt vite
normalement quatre ans que 80 donc c'est
une décision responsable
on doit jouer pour air 4,5 alors après
là je suis partagé parce que je peux me
dire je peux laisser faire les 4 pour
ensuite bouger mon cavalier c6 force et
1,5 et jonquilles des 5 séries ce qu
elle parce qu'évidemment tu peux
toujours te prendre une méga attaque sur
le roi ou alors je peux essayer de jouer
keyyo 5 tout de suite mais auquel cas il
ya sans doute vous b5 pénible ce qui est
une autre option
probablement alors là faut voir des
coups comme dame 17 par exemple sur f 4
kg 4 sans doute avec elle les aide
pourquoi pas sur f 4 kgs c55 maintenant
qu'il prend des 3 des 5 es tu fais un
peu tueur menace du mazout vous oui et
puis tu élimines le fou détroit qui a
une place offensif primordial voilà donc
aidé c'est un bon coup un cinquième set
c'est vraiment un bon coup et et en plus
tu évites faire et surtout v5 tacaille
c5 tu coupes la colonne you wanna il
joue pas mal paramin se meut juste l art
évidemment tous les indiens pensais que
ça arrive très mauvaise marion n'est pas
ram 5 semblait plus costaud encore son
mais pas pour très longtemps mais mais
les costauds suis d'accord avec toi en
plus sur un match comme ça je pense que
parra mais plus fort ouais mais après
après je les vois je les vois quand même
beaucoup plus faible que les joueurs du
top encore tous ces jeunes normalement
beaucoup plus faible déjà en théorie
dans la théorie c'est un énorme problème
à votre niveau
il ya par un tacle g5y si marrant si
mais bon ça change pas grand chose tu
peugeot psa est faible en 3d nuit et je
sais pas c'est cet hommage aux la f3a
les blocs
ils bloquent le fou et il veut gagner le
pion des quatre tranquillement claouey
je pense que siri hélas il sera un
samedi le rapt est dépassé par âme dans
un an tension mémoire s et impressionne
pas si facile d'être au niveau 2 par am
c'est pas mal celui qui est pas mal
c'est ça doit ni oui oui oui bon après
il se cache aussi ses formes soins qui
sont plus forts ça doit ni du cash que
prague amanda sarine
je pense aussi mais bon après tain plus
fort au même âge en tout cas plus fort
mais ma joie après ça va pas dire grand
chose mais oui du coup il ya une naïve
sur sarine parce qu'il un bond énorme
boulette mais
on a bien vu le vélo bullet après y'a
pas énormément de joueurs qui passent
leurs journées à traire +0 en plus on
n'a pas vu parce que en plus sensée
évidemment pas pareil quand en plus 0
mais enfin le bullet impuissant pour moi
c'est pas du bullet déjà j'aime pas trop
cette cadence autant 3 +15 plus un jeu
comprend autant je mettrais je
changerais l'impuissant un + 0 quoi
soyons sérieux
évidemment si tu veux pas que ce soit
trop important tu mets 20 minutes au
lieu de 30 mais bon le bullet c'est du
bullet quoi open à gagner de manière à
vous il a filé la dame en a mais alors
pas par contre par un homme qui ne fait
pas les voir qui c'est qui a vu des
vidéos qui sait que c'est très difficile
de jouer avec une dame de plus c'était
hilarant tout de suite mais je galère
avec une dame de plus en vite c'est
insupportable mais moi j'adore avoir une
dame de moi parce que des tonnes de
pièces tu peux faire tilter l'adversaire
moi j'adore ah ouais mais c'est un tilt
pas possible il a rendu tout de suite il
a même pas hésité quoi ouais mais là il
va la gagner facile
allez c'est cool cette petite victoire
de paraboles à qui se profilerait news
je vais te le montre à la kabylie fait
pas la tête des grands jours eh ben il
est pas content là ça c'est sûr allez 35
minutes de jeu faut par contre faut pas
la rater
là faut essayer de pas trop se poser de
questions côté iranien a clairement faut
se dire que c'est un mec lambda en fasse
un faux pas bon il a pas de raison que
ça mais il se pose pas trop de questions
en général c'est parole ça fait partie
de la catégorie des joueurs qui sont
plus optimistes d'ailleurs il a dit dans
une interview d'avant-match que s'il
jouait son meilleur niveau c'est à 50 50
c'est bien c'est bien c'est le bon état
d'esprit est bon évidemment c'est par
contre c'est complètement faux mais oui
mais ça c'est pas grave oui c'est pas
grave baptême mois parfois ça m'est
reproché en stream d'ailleurs moins
maintenant mais plus avant mais tu vois
quand j'allais jouer que ce soit contre
des gens comme comme toi ou
ouais pourquoi j'étais toujours en mode
ouais ok ça va je vais je préfère ma
game et ça va bien se passer ça veut pas
dire que je le savais en fait oui mais
ça veut juste dire que c'est d'ailleurs
t'as gilles simon qui a parlé de ça j'ai
pas si tu as vu avec que gueule c'est ça
ouais je sais pas si tu as vu en fait il
expliquait que c'est un énorme problème
en france c'est que si tu dis bon bah
mon ambition c'est de gagner en grand
chelem et d'être numéro un mondial droit
il a pris le melon machin alors que et
ensuite si tu es éliminé derrière et on
dire n'importe quoi il s'est vu beaucoup
trop beau et c'est oui alors alors que
les américains aux ospreys de questions
comme ça s'est passé là pour wii et donc
il expliqué qu'en fait si tu dis ça
c'est pas forcément que tu y crois
vraiment mais c'est dans l'attitude le
jour où tu arrives en demi finale de
grand chelem ou quoi inconsciemment dans
ta tête en fait un truc concret qui
s'était préparé pour ce jour là était
prêt pour ça en fait il expliqué ça
agile et j'ai trouvé ça hyper
intéressant en fait ouais ben
sincèrement oui oui clairement mais
clairement clairement c'est sûr on
attend ces trois noms mais bien sûr bah
voilà deux filles magnus qui se lève on
est au magnus qui se lève
ouais ça m'arrive un certain john c
attention mesdames et messieurs à lundi
on n'est pas bien ah oui c'est attention
à complètement interdit ça casse ça
casse le rythme du match ça c'est djoko
appel fin du set appel au kiné annoncé
djoko qui réclame l'interruption du
match et de revenir le lendemain
entretiennent à olemps incroyable ça
assez moche de faire ça quand même non
là c'est pas c'est pas cool ah bah oui
l'un messi doit faire pitié moyart j'ai
attendu la fin de la pause pour aller
faire pipi c'est quand même la règle ou
alors je fais pipi new bumpers qui
ignorent pas peur c'était bien quoi ah
non ça c'est un peu moche parce que ça
c'est les gars c'est ça c'est vraiment
un truc et maxime j'imagine que tu va
confirmer ça peut vraiment cassé le
rythme
ça peut vraiment faire une fois après
non sap ag sap a duré assez longtemps là
ça durait qu'un secondes ça va encore
mais quand même on met de côté par am du
coup tient pour la peine tu as fait la
nef allaient faire cela chevolleau
parvanov passage solo my knees karsten
champion du monde et où je suis
impressionné impressionné c'est la
berlinoise
alors ça le retour de manu salade
derniers mois c'est inattendu
bon il a joué souvent dans sa carrière
mais mais c'est vrai qu'il était plus
sûr le combo nage of may donc là où ils
ferment à se draper
j'ai dit j'ai une évidence et j'ai
rajouté des machines eekhof en fait
ouais ouais mais georges frêche
ouais et là du coup il utilise un peu ma
stratégie contre sarid j'ai l'impression
c'est à dire qu'ils commencent par un
âge d'or est pas très bien il joue
brayard il n'était pas très bien de
clyde tente perminov je pense qu'il va
tenter d ouverture jusqu'à ce que
jusqu'à ces doubles m6 qui l'obtient
voilà il trouve le trou et qu'il y
rentrer parce qu'à ce tracé et c'est
aussi ce à quoi il ya la différence ne
prépare entre les joueurs du top niveau
c'est que bon le camp bitam accepter
pour le coup je n'ai jamais joué un
tournoi
et voilà moi j'étais un peu moins bien
mais mais comment là je réponds pour
aussi bien connaître autant d'ouvertures
thulé travail même si tu les joues pas
non mais à force de voir des partis
puis c'était position enfin je veux dire
j'ai pas les détails de la théorie mais
je peux jouer je peux joindre un bide à
m'accepter sans attributs culot d
ouverture d'argent évidemment accepté
dans sur sur des cap des cinq ans soit
c'est assez simple comme truc la clc
saint-hubert rarement tout de suite
et puis surtout l'idée c'était qu'il n'y
avait aucune chance qu'il soit préparé
dessus oui bah oui
voilà je joue jamais donc façon il était
forcément préparée sur sur la grille une
faible même si c'était probable que la
joues pas tu es obligé de te préparer on
vient de choper la fronde paige ouais on
les traîne ça fait plaisir ça fait
plaisir en plus le match ait du suspense
pour le coup et ouais j'ai dit je voyais
bien par à me tenir le choc
au moins dans la première balle à ça
fait une heure de jeu ça fait tout pile
tout pile une heure n'est pas à tromper
donc tour d2 il veut tourner en moi
j'aime bien et blanc ici écoutant après
je sais que les berlinoise je suis a
estim toujours les blancs parce que je
suis resté mais la structure mais je
sais pas je sais je vois des scénarios
arrivait avec détour d un des cas il
prend ses sept des eaux 6 peut-être même
le truc c'est que j'aime bien la jouer
en petites saletés noir parce que je
sais que c'est sain assez bien jouer sa
carrière voici classique mais bien joué
oui en plus après je dis classique mais
ça reste un mot de la fin ça reste assez
rare dans ces circonstances de joe kg 7
km 6 kg 4 ça me fait toujours peur les
coups comme g4 ouais parce que l'alliage
cinq noms dont j'aurais joué cinq direct
et puis en plus tu te cloud lecavalier
je pense que je suis arrivé parce que
cette part alors il joue comme ça je
suis pas certain je mettrais bien leur
ont à eux deux mais j'ai peur de me
prendre un truc avec un quartier qui
jaillit un donc cette parade qui joue h
4 à voir là je suis dépassée parce
qu'après h5 ça devient de plus en plus
dangereux et ils laissent faire là
j'imagine h5
enfin si les changes les pioches je suis
dépassée complètement anormal aventure
plutôt fermé cette colonne dans le sens
yeux pas de faire mais moi j'ai cherché
ouvrir là depuis tout à l'heure je
cherchais à venir avec les noirs je suis
complètement d'être passé
oui bien sûr je me trompe peut-être
enfin parce que j'ai pas trop
d'expérience de cette position excellent
mois mais je veux dire que j'ai pas en
tout cas j'aurai pas jouer sur pour
jouer h4h prendrait 5 ça c'est sûr ce
que j'aime pas avec avec les blancs ici
c'est vraiment le combo du cavalier 6
pouces et 6 face à face à ce cavalier là
dès que tu bouges ce cavalier du temps
froid et il faut jettera aussi les bobos
et dès que vous le cavalier f3 qui
franck et des quatre timbres sont toutes
les pièces sont attachés quoi j'ai dit
j'ai pas trop d'expérience sur le
terrain avec les noirs s'est obstinée
pas pareil avec les plantes et bien
voilà roi de roanne 3e bien se voir
après au bout de combien d'années de
travail qui paye bien sûr d'avoir
suffisamment d'expérience au moins 50 60
ans non pour être bien sûr et là du coup
ils jouent tour à utah ça c'est dur ça
fait mal c'est très bien vu de la part
de magnus la webreal et connaît bien non
plus l'avantagé de ces lignes c'est que
ouais tu peux jouer facilement pour le
gain elle est noire part en part et
d'autre de la berlinoise bla peut-être
plus on prend b5 c'est peut-être pas si
grave encore est maintenant qu'il ya
plus la pression sur des 5 tu peux bien
sûr toujours qualifiés 3 km 4 logique
puis on prend il faut prendre qu'à elle
et ses trois quatre ans j'ai cinq
d'abord pour avoir la pression sur
plongée 5 et 8 showcase et 3,4 la gg
mechal prochain coup avec les blancs à
tuffé pions b 5 pions g5 qui avait
laissé 3 qui a aidé 400 l'écrit couvé
aimait bien vu un
je pense n'a pas le choix faut jouer
comme ça une question me diagne l'onu si
on prend toujours du plaisir à jouer aux
échecs 1 - carrément vrai ils sont là
aujourd'hui quand j'ai commencé à bisser
sert pour ça que j'étais belle moi je
prends plus de plaisir à jouer qu'à
travailler les échecs a bien sûr
enfin je veux dire je ne m'amuse pas une
cure jt dictum de théories sur la neige
dark cloud celle des autres et autres
joyeuseries si c'est pour ne pas prendre
du plaisir quand je dis donc il commence
par prendre angers 5 avril est peut-être
prison ces cartes par contre ouais mais
c'est pas grave parce que j'aime en c4
apprête à la colonne b dont klaus
je pense que mike bliss va prendre
angers 5 mai les y réfléchisse parce que
je pense qu'il a vu depuis en trombe et
5 l'angleterre
oui et du coup ils jouent tour à 3 voilà
[Musique]
c'est ça qu'ils laissent par contre ça
il n'aurait pas dû lui laisser
alors après c'est peut-être pas si grave
mais faut calculer il faut calculer
genre qui comprend piscine pour prendre
des 3 4 et ensuite tu prend 1,6 ou alors
qu'ils ont franchi ou prend un chiffre 4
pour itunes est la cas là je suis
reprend du cavage
après faut pas que laurent blanc soit
trop claustrophobe ans parce que près de
60 ans pas le choix non en vrai l'un
autour des 3 stif et c'est plus
raisonnable mais du coup maintenant si
ta plume trempée 5 ça m'embête c'est
très chiant ça non gentille cavaliers
des deux ici à mékhé idée car ça va être
les cas tu tolère et tu prends un griot
4k idée 4e cat way exakis et je vais
bien vu max du canadien 4 et de l'enclos
fouqué français 4 bellechasse et une
gaffe de magnus fait ouais ça c'est une
gaffe mais qui rallie m6 rsa il a réussi
à sortir le cavalier gorille kati 17
secondes ça par contre pour le coup
l'opposition encore très chaude
j'aime pas autour des 4 c'est bien joué
très bon coup à tour des quatre un
horrible tour à tour des quatre fois il
peut prendre peut prendre je voulais
mais après rodez 3 il y avait payé ses 5
je pose des problèmes arrivent de
partout là c'est une horreur à défendre
moi ça va être très très dur mais bon là
toi sans doute il n'aura pas tour des
parce qu' à tout reprendre et à la
prendre quatre jeunes en bref des bas
mais c'est dur à c'est trop dur à
défendre la whey je peux pas bouger le
foot aura déclaré la fin car elle sait
bien jouer faut ensuite en plus moi il
va tomber y attendait kébé deux là sont
un tour à deux non non on décale
d'accord fou un fou pour à 2 sinon la
toile de ça fait marrer magnus qu'il a
vraiment dominé celle là ouais mais
panama parham un peu tendre à dans ce
duo bon après on avait vu d'estimations
chaise comme pour ce même c'était 22,7
je crois je pense que ce sera beaucoup
moins quand même enfin les cas sera
beaucoup moins important alors comme on
le disait il ya les seuls qui peuvent
vraiment mettre magnus en danger c'est
hikaru s laisse aux toits et artemiev et
peut-être nile rogers l'épaule qui prend
part aux jo les autres en fait même pas
la peine ouais enfin magnus qui
réfléchit pour être bien sûr que tour
auto gagne mais ça y est menée sur bram
qui a réussi à jouer puisqu'ils est
quand même un exploit en soi
ouais il a peut-être cavaliers à 5,6 à
non plus ce qui tient well as des trop
ça va ça va fermer la partie comprend
lequel des deux mondes qu'il réussit à
rester en vie un petit et un petit peu
par am
longtemps que ça voilà qui c'est simple
acquis et ses 5e jeux simples tous
gagnants voilà c'est facile plan d'aidé
en plus après la raison de la joue un
peu avec les blancs bas ne serait ce que
pour gratter du chrono ce qu' a priori
ils disent plus les boulettes où il ya
plus d'expérience oui là il nous restera
de bliss s'il fait dur un peu cela il
nous restera deux pays six font tourner
à -2 ce serait bien au moins ça va être
dur voilà mais ce quartier des plus
forts que firent ou de gens habitent sur
internet à moi je mettrais quand même à
retenir faute sur encore après fear
objet il progresse tellement vite
6 heures pas évident pas évident de
savoir mais contre hikaru c'est un
magnifique à roues ce sera un match
intéressant non il n'aura pas lieu mais
ça pourrait à ça pourrait être un duel
intéressant même si pour moi magnus est
beaucoup plus fort mais après j'ai été
étonné de la résistance d'hikaru lors
des dernières compétitions donc ce sera
intéressant à suivre
bien sûr
donc pourquoi il n'aura pas lieu puisque
maxime aura éliminé l'un des deux avant
et oui comment comment le match peut
avoir lieu
ils ont déjà perdu le bas qui ce temps
libre et indépendant va représenter oui
mais toi c'est contre ces comptes ricard
ou que tu as un peu de mal j'ai
l'impression enfin c'est un peu le
joueur difficile dans ce format là ouais
mais alors aussi ce qui se passait c'est
que il se préparait à chaque fois mois
je me préparais pas dans les ouvertures
et du coup j'ai beaucoup souffert de ça
dans menard miss pitch est ce rythme
était rythme et entre nous je vois
l'italienne à tout va avec les blancs et
puis puis souvent ils égalisaient trop
facilement et du coup je crois que j'ai
tenu les 18 premières parties que jeunes
et envolées ouais il y avait quelque
chose comme 8,9 une fuite chez plus pour
qui et puis après c'était à et je suis
en plus après bon à la fin je joue mon
va-tout et les points s'enchaînent quoi
donc
après on se réfère de perte de trois
points 10 points pour moi ça fait aucune
différence donc
donc ouais mon objectif c est du coup
magnus qui jouent et 4 1 dans cette
partie un lap à noter mais renonce à
cette radio usine pour l'instant il est
parti il est parti sur ces partis sur
une petrov et la jouer detroit il n'ya
pas il n'est pas prix le pion aux 5 et
donc oui c'est sûr que s'il joue naka ou
car c'est nous
peu importe qui je vais je vais avoir un
minimum de préparation fait d'ailleurs
manière pas très évolué parce que je
connaissais bien les positions etc
mais j'allais faire un minimum de
cheveux à 2 août façon j'imagine qu'avec
cette crise sanitaire qui continue t
obligé d'être motivé sur des tournois
sur internet même si c'est pas la
panacée a été obligé de chercher un peu
de la compétition et de reprendre
où es-tu de manière générale j'aime bien
c'est ce pitch est alors après
évidemment quand à quant à trois grands
prix fille d'une coupe du monde et les
grandes chaînes tour à côté bon si c'est
plus dur de prendre la compétition au
sérieux
après un peu un peu un peu court les
matches mais après courtrai quoi à part
ça à part ça tu étais au tableau mais je
sais que tu aimes bien les speechs s du
général tu me l'as tu as toujours dit ça
d'ailleurs que c'est une compétition
qu'il plaisait voilà bah je trouve qu'il
ya trop de pose est ce que là c'était
horrible le premier match il ya déjà il
a commencé un petit peu en retard mais
en plus entre le 5 puis 5-3 plus simple
tu as eu près de dix minutes de pause je
sais on attendait on sait pas trop quand
ça reprenait
est-ce que du coup c'est une ligne qui
peut compter au palmarès une ligne de
vainqueur de ce pitch s offre quand même
moins bonne de tous les plus forts là
cette année c'est une île qui compte ce
que oui bah de toute façon c'est comme
quand j'ai battu magnus à londres la sur
le sur le match batman nice un match
quel que soit le format quelles que
soient les cadences c'est pas donné à
tout le monde dans ce pas évident non
c'était à londres en demi après oui il
aurait fallu gagner la finale pour que
pour que ça compte mais oui mais c'était
un super match je peux tu avais réalisé
voilà oui donc là c'est plutôt bien pour
les blancs n'ont pas gagné la seule
colonne ouverte puisque way pour batman
plus bas en match en tout cas alors lui
évidemment unis doivent probablement pas
être à 100% pour que ça puisse arriver
mais si moi je suis pas à 100% ou en
tout cas dans un état proche de 100% ça
va être dur ça va être très dur
oui je me lance des fleurs tout à fait
ça l'hocine ce que manu c'est un crack
itoïz 5 à quito magnus sais pas si
voudra jouer à vendredi yannick ratisse
tôt
track it up mais bon moi je sui team
sunn je suis à montrer la puissance des
cinq compagnies allaient la team savez
la team savez là bas kiki et imsa pas
font un terrible
et ben moi aussi je suis team surf
oui je siège d'allemand vous allez
peut-être devoir rencontrer un crack ito
vendredi16 au var a prouvé sa puissance
ouais la team se peut pas mettre sur
pied cette affaire banon même moi je
peux pas de bonnes pâquis sur czech com
fr mais d'ailleurs d'envoi le chat en en
a' bonic mans aussi il n'y a pas grand
monde qui peut parler mais les prime ils
peuvent parler c'est ça quand même
non non faut que les primes soient seuls
kanté prime foutu soit ça va la chaîne
ah oui où ça fait mal ça ça fait très
mal lui qui a fait très très mal à
l'équipe qui va se présenter avec l'épée
il peut parler l'été l'éternel se sauver
est-ce que parra missiles pas en train
de faire un bel effort de cette partie
fille bas il est pas mal
oui c'est vrai que je pensais qu'on
n'est pas bien moi je pensais qu'il
n'était pas bien tout à l'heure avec la
colonne des pour magnus et tout ça non
moi je pensais qu'il était tout le temps
bien mais là ça tourne pas mal en plus
ouais ça tourne pas mal ya la colonie et
à l'activité la tête je ferai un truc
genre monsieur toute façon les blondes
pas beaucoup de plans leur seul plan
c'est kg 4 donc là j'aurais payé h7
et si tu joues h4 pour empêcher du kg 5
tu reviens bref si c'est la fameuse
question de flat pourquoi tu joues
afrique et m6 lé ton plan pourquoi tu
veux on est on est plus de 5000 1 ohlala
abbas est là
quant à beaucoup de gens qui s'engagent
plus la première page beaucoup de monde
pense qui hier si on avait la première
page pour ton match on aurait été plus
de 6000 je pense qu'à un moment donné
j'avais vraiment beaucoup de monde
bah ouais ça fait plaisir en tout cas ah
bah oui ça aurait été mieux que ce soit
sur le stream que sur chaise comme est
fermée dans le crash
acheter un jouet sagem - alors su
recueillir 3 son idée c'est sans doute
h4 mais du coup voilà h4 les tours à 2
alors après ils sont à peu près à
égalité au temps behiels troyat kg 4 ah
mais du coup c'est pas mal qui est de
3,6 kg 3 kg 4 c'est pas mal allez faut
qu'il gagne on est on à quoi je jette un
petit coup d'oeil aux hôtes en 13
minutes 12 devrait donc tu as raison ça
là elle va durer il reste deux partis
assis légaliste c'est bien moi donc 3 8
cm avoir un tourin way qu'elle 3 kg caf
alors qu'elle 3 j'aime pas ta cieux kg 4
et je pense qu'en fait si tu joues ton
des huit je vais prendre un joker fuite
et j'en ai rien à [ __ ] de toi des huit
donc calé j'ai comme ça l'air très fort
pour moi une 30 pour par amy les deux
nouveaux pas si mal autant alors on
demande qui a la meilleure cogné deux
montres magnifique à l'aube alors
maintenant on n'a plus droit de se
serrer la main mais maintenue s'il a une
bonne pointe quand il sert la main les
carreaux un peu fuyant nom sur la coupe
a pas spécialement non mais pour le coup
maintenue s'il fait d'être up car il
fait d'être up
il fait des trump ouais donc ça va
changer quatre dante 3 mai ok du coup
son idée c'est surtout première strophe
c'est le pion à cinq pieds pas bien mais
là tu vois j'ai envisagerait même des
trucs genre cahier fut de kyé ossi
est-ce que je pense aussi redone légion
après j'ai pas spécialement envie de
donner plus en d3 non plus mais dont ce
genre là d'un petit tour b 8 mai auquel
manu cheveux qu'ai-je dessin c'est pour
ça c'est pour ça que les chiites tombé à
8 kg cinq cahiers fuite mais donne le
pion aux 6 1 ouais mais tombait ville
qui est gestion qui a fait puisque sur
son champion prends tu insistes enfermé
le cavalier j'aurais peut-être jeu comme
ça donc il va là il veut il veut
cavaliers s'il va faire car le système
pose imagine elle est la cible en mieux
ouais je pense un an
quoique voyez pas moins bien en tout cas
derrière dubai en d4 a offert les scalps
et 4 et le cavaliere des 4 x factor mais
si je fais dame c3 ici west point et
trois des quatre intermédiaires pour 30
des deux tapes tête retournée donne mais
au tournant vers la whey et la boîte on
va retrouver sur la partie oui on va
retourner soit parti mais il a fait dame
c3 bader ça peut être la partie pour un
f3 b4 peut-être non non n'a pas fait du
coup j'ai six d'accueil des quatre là
non ouais j'ai six sur cette route qui
détiennent tout de suite mais après ça
changera insultant décès du chanteur
explique simplement quand même un filtre
et tu fait cavaler des cathos prochain
je pense pas que tu ce moment bien avec
les noirs et surtout avec peu de temps à
la pendule c'est beaucoup plus facile à
jouer avec les noirs ça que magnus il a
plus trop de temps là ouais faut tenter
un truc moi je dis faux-plat jeu pour la
gagne celle là ce qui a aidé quatre là
non il faut pas qu'il prenne trop de
temps par am
bon après il a droit de prendre du temps
là c'est la fin de la partie donc à un
moment une vente de toute façon toutes
les deux se retrouvaient à égalité au
temps assez sûr c'est sûr mais après je
veux qu'il fasse gaffe à sa connexion
aussi la liste mais en dessous de 10
secondes j'aime pas trop quoi wen mais
qu'elle jouit toujours d'un merci c'est
que le terme de trois heures et va
récupérer depuis on b2f au prince 5 à
des revenus très bien vu de la part de
magnus ouais c'était le petit piège dans
lequel il fallait pas tomber dans
l'excès de là sans doute mais il a tombé
la terrible sur le procès du père bo5
et si tu perds cinq tu la partie voulais
prendre ma chance m'a prêté mc2 s'était
pas encore claires ferry je ne tape pas
tu avais pas tout prendre et si spéciaux
qui on prend un prg mpf de été attaqué
par la tour et cuite aussi et la dame
touré projet à cause de 2.4 donc ça le
jeu de monsieur et je pense que ça va je
trouve que magnus est quand même passé
impérial que ça un an ce match pour le
moment pour le moment je ne mens pas
après c'est suffisante parce qu'il est
il a une marge en veuille ou non c'est
sur ces suffit c'est suffisant mais
mais clairement ça suffirait pas à
contre un des gars dont on apparemment
contraintes sur waka on accueillir mort
six jeux comme ça ah oui non content
makala ce serait serait pas suffisant
mais même quand ils roulent déjà
artemiev ou quoi je pense que ce serait
juste
ouais après bon faut aussi souligner par
am c'est un bon match alors après il est
pas récompensé il a moins deux n'a
objectivement il pourrait facilement
être à 50% dans ce match oui enfin bon
match il joue bien il joue bien les
manuellement au dessus quoi et j'habite
en france dans la péninsule du bâti ce
temps à l'ambassade du pakistan à paris
même ouais c'est ça qui est très bien
situé donc il a fait rage 4,5 j'aime
bien ces trucs là avec les noirs ah
ouais moi j'aime bien avec les grands
aussi généralement loge tu joues un
souper deux hommes ces deux tu laisses
faire
j'aime bien jouer ça avec les blancs la
prière 5 voilà il va sans doute jouer
tes 3 des 4 as pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
c'est peut-être une prépa je ne franchis
pas si c'est une très bonne idée puisque
après ta phu et trois dames d2 je pense
m'être une prépa côté blanc peint
possible déjà foule trop par exemple sur
le camp rock jazz des 5 es tu gagnes une
pièce quand un quart le quart eli et le
fou il faut prendre 3 des français 6 la
retrouver un coup c'est pas évident bah
ouais mais deux titres rock c'est pas là
par exemple que des cinq peut-être
dans lequel j'ai 51 ans a chuté 3 tu
reprends du fou sur kaia cinq jours plus
tôt de 3,8
il a fait ces cinq à ça ça ne c'est pas
mal aussi ça me plaît c'est ça tu joues
du produit dans le détroit
le pian des cas très sécurisé maintenant
et le x 7 et 1 pas beau c'est un plot ça
mange annonce victoire de parme dans
cette partie je me mouille gens voient
les prédictions sur salat tu te mouiller
à fond à 6 minutes de jeu dans la
cadence donc ouais ce sera la dernière a
priori a priori de cette cadence et on
va passer après trois puissants ce
serait bien une victoire de parham pour
sa part exemple tapez 3 moi je suis le
grand roque tu vois ça c'est ce que
j'aurais joué tempo tu vois pas ce que
les n'auront pas les moyens de créer une
attaque sur le roi dont tu te mets
laurent b2 il est très safe est ce que
le x 7 ne peut pas à revenir poser des
cas de problème sur casse noix wade est
complètement fermée dans les barèmes qui
réfléchit magnus aussi l'art watch cette
salle à partir faut aussi c'est pas
possible de les voir des 5 1 qui doit
gagner tout de suite cet ouvrage suite
hein c'est pareil ailleurs racheté mg
mais moins dans le sens tu peux te faire
toucher par un cavalier g5 ou un fou sur
la diagonale est donc là fécamp rock
il reste trois sets donc là il joue
tenter des choses têtes raides pays elle
5 mais là je pourrais dire par exemple
pour h&m est sûr que yelle 5 kgs r4
rachat cavalli a fait 5 cavale f4 tu
protèges le fou est tu après il ya
peut-être du cac et prend des cartes
l'ajecta de gaffer mais avec la colonie
sinon qu'est hier 4 tout de suite est
sûr que y avait 5 et des 5 mai auquel
kayak ou g8 quotas que ça justifie
peut-être cailly cédé 5 pour empêcher le
g8 selon quel cahier de la mef certains
pensaient peut-être un bon coup fois
cette barre beaucoup ça libère la case
f5 pour le cavalier ça donne des fous g8
et ça empêche je prends des échecs sur
la colonnade jamais alors après il ya
des cinq quand même qui viennent une
pièce s'agit pas penser que cinq c6
après c'est pas vraiment une pièce parce
que presse a créé un bordel monstre un
méga coup prend 1,3 et check call of
duke ou roy b2 le problème c'est propre
et docks et f5 dessin qui accueille
points trois jeunes français si ce qui
était un échec
donc il faudrait jouer des 5,1 et 5,3 b2
mais non pas comme ça qu'il faut jouer
allez pas facile à jouer cela pourra
pour les blancs tour d2 ah ouais il veut
des cinq 5 c et 6 c sur fou prend 1,3 il
aura pu comprendre ce que c'est plus sûr
échec c'est chaud quand même des studios
radio qui d'être aux échecs car à la fin
faut calculer c'est pas est ce qu'il le
veut vraiment on sait pas maintenant
tous les cas tour des 2,5 ou utile ouais
ouais c'est plutôt un bon coup du coup
ouais c'est chose faite car il y avait
cinq quand même
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'ils jouent des 5
bat f cell à 9,7
il est beaucoup trop malin ça fait très
mal ça et sur roy b2 du coup cavalier e
5 il n'ya plus le c6 qui attaquent la
dame
terrible prête à des coups comme kiev
catry caille aussi sa possible katz
apparaître un bon coup afin qu'il
réussisse et des clous et amis barragan
hisse à la magnus à 100 well as l'air
compliqué ça sent que il joue mieux quoi
pourtant là ouais trop new york a
peut-être jusqu'à prendre 3 ou 6 max
prix comprend tout reprend qui est aussi
de mettre six robes et 2 j'ai pas c'est
pas pas fini
ça sent que c'est en train de tourner
non ouais il y aura sans doute un truc
en tout cas ouais terrible terrible
parra masseret en 3 +16 mais si ce n'est
en pression de temps ils mangent comme
saint thomas le truc c'est surtout que
la dynamique du match va être
complètement faveur de bus après c'est
surtout ça d'ailleurs s'il ya une cas
d'une reste grèce une 40 tu sais qu'il
peut y avoir encore une partie en 5 + 1
abbaoui gare à wii fit jour plus et tu
vois ça ça peut être infernal ce que
s'il en a encore une de plus et il a
finalement joué au kenya 4 3 je pense
qu'il va réussir à tenir une minute de
jeu parce que même si je dois quand même
chercher à finir proprement
il reste une 17 ouais mais ce serait la
mauvaise news pour lui oui donc quelques
ya quatre mois il protège les pions
c'est ce à quoi il perdra pas tout de
suite si par beau temps il perdra pas
tout de suite sur tout est protégé
il a finalement trouvé la bonne case
prouve cavaillé c'est vrai que là mais
moi j ai pas pensé laquelle à 4 mais
c'est évidemment bon coup et prend 1,3
et adam eve 2 n'ont peut-être ces jeunes
français six prêtres des cinq mais là
j'étais pas sûr que tu prends tu as l
touré fin mai à dessein droit et
accueillez à s'impliquer à 5 ans et 8
storming c'est fini duel de cavalia
n'sele et hors série tour ces quatre
noms des c4 avec la cecafa c'est fini
alors attends je regarde le chrono 15
secondes
il a évité la partie plus normalement
l'ail est à 5 bat new skies force pas 5
4 3 2 à il va il va éviter la partie
plus de justesse 1
si la villa à la seconde près et voilà
ne fait pas pas plus qu éviter la partie
et ça va faire ça à faire leur des cas
et là ça va apporter 100 à tan tan tan
tan est ce qu'on n'aurait pas un chrono
dé calais ou je sais pas quoi
ah ils ont peut-être compter le camp
magnus est parti à 15 20 secondes de
plus ça oui et oui sa part au match tout
de suite
et voilà et voilà maxime médard à la
portée de plus et louis forcément comme
manu s'est élevé ça rajoute et 15
secondes et ça s'est joué à rien aïe aïe
aïe le marlou taz nous dit nous dit
ludwig abbas la bonne nouvelle c'est que
ça allait faire jouer les timides de
plus comme ça on est un peu plus chargé
oui oui bien sûr c'est pour ça qu'on est
sûr parce que s'ils savaient pas jouer
on n'aurait pas été c'est sûr que ça non
évidemment là on va dire quand même on
est jamais trop sûr bien sûr que non
mais j'allais trop science a fait + 3
points côté à côté magnus
s'ils venaient à tourner à plus 4 j'ai
envie de te dire ouais un ballet les
deux heures qui d 1h30 de matchs
restants seront assez longue ça je m'en
tiens je suis très expérimenté mon cher
maxime et j'ai envie de te dire tu le
dis à quelqu'un de bien au courant mais
bon c'est pour ça que je dis toujours
que s'il restait huit ou neuf heures de
matches derrière ce serait plus
intéressant c'est ça devient chiant ça
pourrait plus facilement retourner là
c'est le fait qu'il reste pas ces temps
de jeu qui a mis rend la chose qui rend
la chose difficile c'est my way le
pauvre né à lille se retrouve à moins 4
avant les boulettes
après lille était sous pression il a été
forcé de faire le beau jeu et tout est
descendu à - 5 mai s'il avait eu deux
heures de jeu de boules est il aurait pu
gérer son retard bien sûr tu dis ça à
quelqu'un qui a su le match donné pau
qui a gagné 19 films montrent danielian
oui ce n'est pas devant la fin
29 arrêts peut-être tu parle à des gens
très sérieux
magnus avec les sponsors dr tu n'y
penses pas kevin incrusté sur le fond de
verre et qui défilent non mais j'ai pas
de sponsor en même temps tu vas donc
c'est compliqué ah ouais c'est aux
prépas sur l'italienne très théorique
c'est cette théorie met d'ailleurs sur
pièces comme sfr doit pas y avoir la
commande point d'exclamation cornette
non terrible terrible hein pourquoi tu
joues et en plus je pense que l'epo face
parce que je pense mais c'est que sa
santé que les paul était quasiment
content d'en perdre une
ouais alors que n'a qu'à lui il avait
vraiment tenté de faire très mal à willy
fans ouais ouais pareil en fait moi
c'était de dire j'en ai je t'avais dit
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] de perte de trois
points et 10 points est pareil j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] de gagner trois points 10
points
pour moi c'est la victoire qui compte
bien sûr c'est logique
après je pense ça te met mal à l'aise de
mettre 30 0 à quelqu'un peut-être comme
ses films et où l'anc et 29,1 c'est
quand même mieux que 30 0 bien sûr à un
moment donné je passe je dis bon c'est
déjà assez humiliant 29,1 30,0 c'est
quand même
ouais après tu vas pas faire espère
donner un second prime non mais
peut-être inconsciemment tu lâches un
peu oui
bookeen à jouer on va dire plus
spectacle voilà mais en même temps tu
sais que tu fais pas exprès de perdre
donc là la position un peu mieux pour
les blancs non tu vas pouvoir taper
colonne c'est un peu fou j'ai cinq tours
c'est un jet pack stream
ouais mais ça va pour les non c'est
plutôt tranquille donc par am ne perdra
pas cette partie encore une preuve en
pronostiquant carton du du joueur
français
ah oui la dernière tu avais victoire de
parham quand même voix la haye a trouvé
des bons coups mamie naissance des
règles seraient serait-il un bon joueur
d'échecs
la question se pose la question est très
tabou mais la question se pose un peu
plus que se poser un plâtre qui avait
dit raconté que commenter le match de
part à mme rahma grande époque et ce
qu'ils en auraient pris une
la question se pose est jolie le
commentaire d'un terrain magic après la
10 voire un peu un peu beau souvent
c'est pour ça qu'avec maso il pourrait
faire un stream exceptionnel lanterne
magique si personnellement j'aime bien
ces formats de speechless mais c'est
vrai que je rejoins votre avis lorsqu'il
s'agit des matchs à sens unique sans
doute qu'au bout d'un certain écart il
faut répartir la canon suivante bas
c'est ce dont on a souvent parlé
lanterne magique en vrai si tu as un
bachus
dans ce cas c'est 17 parce que c'est
moche de passer la cadence suivante
imagines-tu mais il imagine je commence
par 4 0 comme sarine et là on me dit bah
ya trop d'écart on passe à la cadence
suivante et du coup admettons qu'ensuite
il gagne la cadence suivante 7 5 et que
deux points d'écart mais c'est pas oui
c'est pas voilà non mais en fait il y
avait il y avait deux idées avaient soi
l'idée 17
parce qu'en fait le truc c'est que si
c'est un match amical c'est nous ou ou
carlson naka ou carlson finir ou jacques
wattez que tu es content de voir trois
heures trente mais le truc c'est que des
matches comme ça sur sur les 55 miles
efficace dans l'année il y en a six et
tu te tapes pâte à 30 matches qui sont
vraiment sens unique est en a 15 tu sais
pas vraiment avant et un assist qui sont
vraiment chaud mais avec honnêtement je
pense que
vraiment honnêtement pour ces matches là
et encore la parole se défend bien et
tout mais là par exemple pour le match
de daniel y en est tout moi j'aurais
laissé l'option rizal enfin tu laisses
option rezaï à tout moment tadros design
ton match
oui oui bien sûr enfin après le format
17 et le juste le plus simple et il est
utilisé dans tous les sports individuels
où il ya un système de comptage
waroquier au volley ball wii aubade me
alors au badminton non rituel mais enfin
sauf si sauf les doubles mais n'ont
cessé le sait le sait le système l'a
utilisé dans tous les sports individuels
parce que c'est le sait le plus sympa et
en plus dans des matches comme ça tu
pourras quasiment à voir là un 7-0 on va
dire pour magnus
et puis tu pourrais avoir un semblant de
retournement de situation quoi oui
et attention messieurs tu dois avoir un
7-0 pour magnus et puis tu peux le dire
si tu fais tes si tu fais beaucoup de
cette cour de deux c'est peut-être pas
la même histoire parce que c'était aussi
une balle de set pour parra mais il
trouvait ça peut changer le déroulement
de la partie aussi bien sûr bien sûr
c'est un système de comptage met
justement en fait l'argument c'est qu'on
est moins sûr que le meilleur gagne je
te jure en fait baptême de cette pas si
tu fais en 6 53 ça m'étonnerait que je
le tue c'est moins sûr je te jure que
c'est l'argument en fait je rigole par
en fait oui on est mauvaise
je pense que tu es moins sûr sûr sûr des
très forts joueurs parce que en fait je
pense que ce qui se passe et tu n'as
qu'à c'est que bkc qui a tracé sa
stratégie sia qui est des trois fuites
qui est peut-être la main je fais un
refrain fuite
je vais jouer parce que sinon on fait la
finale avec la tour qui arrive en
cessant cavalli qui jaillit en d4 web en
armes bien sûr mais en fait où est ce
que en fait n'accueille se dit aussi
parce que que tu peux - fertilité des
joueurs parce que tu peux
kit est un ancêtre mais après tu es fort
c'est de remobiliser oui voilà
et ça ça peut changer les dynamiques de
match oui mais du coup du du coup en
fait les règles sont faites pour
favoriser un joueur et pas pour
favoriser le spectacle c'est un peu
dommage c'est un joueur qui pense avoir
besoin un jour mais pas pour favoriser
les dizaines voire centaines de milliers
de gens qui regardent c'est ça c'est
spécial quand même c'est ça ouais mais
bon on est bien sûr le plus important
bah on n'est pas sûr ça dure pas assez
longtemps
oui après oui alors par contre non
gertrude pas ce que c'est
c'est interdit ça nelson monfort patrick
montel patrick montel je peux accepter
c'est un passionné l'essonne c'est très
très très dur la comparaison est très
très dur ouais ça ça s'est très mal
habituellement il ment mais une petite
un bon alors qu'à rallier de d2 et
qu'elle prend vis d'eux masqué prend b3
tomber ça il va la gagner magnus à la
non pourquoi
c'est à s'y tient à dézinguer millions
ouais mais tu joues c'est simple c'est 4
2 6 6 1 oui non je sais 4 ou c4
on va se poser la question qui est mieux
dans cette finale s'il te plaît c'est
pas faut tâter noir qui sont mieux
finalement
il aurait peut-être dû jouer autour des
600 fait le drive de well as et and
you'll du taux en c4 ma vie c'est
davantage la presse ça doit être dans le
règne de nabeul mais aller sera bien sûr
une victoire de parme pour revenir à
deux points à ce serait très beau que
les 15 secondes est de poser fait toute
la différence
c3 c3 c'est pas nul 8 ouvre vraiment le
faire tout de suite par contre c'est
trop lent parce que sinon il a des
droits si différents à des droits c3 il
est mis avec les blancs non question roi
dès cette date elle ces trois chaînes
comme prendre pour des 8 tu forces re 2
e et la torah 8 des gens qui annonce
news
ouais la dernière fois que on m'avait
annoncé news c'était ma news contre
lemon vous avez luis finale difficile à
défendre
il n'avait pas défendu alors la c3 cette
prof je sais trop du coup elle allait à
tours intitulé très malin et tours 4 ah
oui vous là bas c'est pas moins bien
pour les normes non c'est pas moins bien
mais super le bénéfice de ton attaque la
tour et cinq tours angers 5 à 3 des 4
c'est faux c'est faute c'est faute ma
zone tireux [ __ ] de l'activité voile a
tant fait vraiment quelque chose
trois des deux pour trois j'imagine
c'est son idée c'est rob mais attend sa
place et de magie menace trop d'échecs
mais les menaces et attentats non mais
faut pas me de l'altertour bessette
attendait ça madame fini non ccis monast
ont plongé à 8 ans g8 dont j'ai eu
encore raté pour dérober quatre enfants
des deux héros ouais ça s'est terminé
donc comme ça ouais termine à dos à la
la ça fait très mal ça aille là rating
notre case weppes et en plus tu passes à
puis passe à plus 4 comment il peut
abandonner 3com plus ce mois là c'est le
tilt un la setil temps parce qu'ils
étaient à chaque lucide et a deux
ennemis d'ennemis ou treuil 12h30 mais
ça y est l'été il est ta propre il était
il est à trois points et là il passe
passe à 15h56 c'est le scénario n'avait
d'ici à la fin des 5 + 1 et à moins que
le match est terminé
ce qu'on avait dit avant le même moins
bon je pensais qu'ils devaient être à
50% pour avoir une chance mais ouais il
a tenu une heure et puis ensuite place à
la dernière demi-heure a fait très mal
le même scénario s'est vraiment scénario
classique de speech et astia une heure
et après ça lâche mais bon ne t'inquiète
pas maximale et c'est respect ya dix ans
encore
dix bonnes minutes de pause une heure et
encore à peu près une heure 35 non il va
ya voir 20 25 minutes de pause et 1h35
de jeu il reste encore deux heures
histoire de bien s'assurer quand même à
bâle il faut s'assurer il faut s'assurer
à fond après pour un format aussi l'ont
aussi une autre idée que j'avais eue
c'est pour les huitièmes de finale de
jouer deux matchs en même temps
l'histoire de n'en mettre un peu comme
ça déséquilibre est d'être un autre
serré que tu que tu vas avoir dans leur
deuxième temps quoi ouais mais bon après
ça rempiler ça remplit les caisses de
programmation ah bah oui bien comme il
faut d'ailleurs à la petite pub
ah oui la pub situé à la wii mais à lyon
à bas pour être bien sûr allez va de
toute façon faut l'envoyer la pub a été
obligé bien sûr c'est vrai en plus cet
art les directives gp2 séries et en plus
c'est 180 secondes
elle est bonne celle là et en plus ce
nom prem tulle et vite
ah non en prime tu évites pas aulas n'y
fit ah oui elle est belle elle fait du
bien a plus place à la mode du mérite
pas sûr non non tu évites pas ouais bah
faut le symbole pour éviter la pub à la
salle elle fait elle fait plaisir ça la
haye en plus c'est génial d'arad burili
ce point la pub quand harry est
important c'est terrible c'est terrible
mais deux cantons par la pub ils nous
entendent que du coup bah ça dépend y en
a ils n'ont pas tous généralement
généralement ils n'ont pas tout
il ya des gens qui n'ont pas en fait
c'est ya des pans france c'est terrible
ça il ya beaucoup de gens qui foule aux
la chaîne n'hésitez pas tout au long du
coup si vous êtes nouveau surtout si
vous n'êtes en plein public vous ne
l'entendez pas ça fait plaisir
et donc après je sais pas attendre quand
je prends mon téléphone j'ai pour une
seconde maxime
parce qu'après après à 21h30
il ya le capitaine qui va se présenter
c'est ça il faut qu'ils se présentent un
petit peu là parce qu'ils me rattrape un
oui je vais faire un petit sociaux voir
ces derniers résultats voir s'il a une
chance
les gens qui demandent une autre pub
pour être bien sûr ah mais c'est
commentée par par daniel reyne chez et
gotham chef a non non non c'est autre
chose
ah c'était c'était en prime time y avait
un match entre gotham et allaoui ils
font vers cuba yzf-r fondé portier de 27
30 maso il remonte roman qui vient de
gagner une partie mais je pense je pense
que je pense que là je le tiens bien à
l'écart la la je le tiens bien aller car
notre ses batteries avec j'ai fait gro
âgées battu 10 6 1 mais qu'ils étaient
28 45 qui était qu'ils étaient bien les
plus mais j'ai beaucoup de chance j'ai
pris le mec c'était son lots max donc ça
c'est énorme réussite eric du mec tu le
prends tu es heureux et oui c'est
important
j'aurais arménien la famille ça me fait
mal au coeur après battre en arménien
comme ça non mais tu tu maintiens que
l'athée au dessus des de l'excèdent tout
le temps 27 5 ans mais c'est quand même
rien à force de discuter avec toi avec
baky avec maso avec fabulous ça
progresse à bari
c'est terrible de se dire ça arrêtez de
parler à cet homme mairie pendant que
maso régresse
la rend plus masos le truc c'est qu'il a
un style totalement différent du mien
ouais que je progresse à son contact en
fait oui linverse à l'abri basso est un
style différent beaucoup de monde c'est
pas faux nathan et mais il est tout en
optimist en plus ça tu y es fou c'est
une de ses grandes forces je pense gemin
j'aime une belle vidéo en ligne
aujourd'hui je peux montrer le tient je
récupère le petit exemple je récupère le
petit exemple je te le maire à l'écran
ouais on va voir si tu trouves
c'est pendant la pause c'est pas mal
mais je connais j'ai vu bon bah je mets
pour les gens ouais pour les gens moches
comme je connais quand même je connais
mes classiques
je pense que tu as trouvé enfin oui tu
trouves tempo parce que tu sais mais de
toute façon tu trouves tempo parce que
c'est un grand classique
oui mais c'est joli quand tu connais pas
je dis pas le contraire
c'est joli quand tu connais pas ça fait
partie des dépositions simple et
instructive et jolie c'est rare en fait
y'a pas de tant d'exemples que ça dans
ce style la jolie instructif et simple
ouais mais après tout ces trucs là c'est
connu on est au noir de jouer du coup
c'est sur lignon pour ceux qui n'ont pas
vu très haut noir comment vous continuez
un trait au noir ça veut dire au noir de
joueurs en fait stresser
ça veut dire ça donne la couleur qui
joue là ils connaissent tous ils ont vu
ici un truc joly c'est qu'on veut
pousser les pions et du coup le fou bloc
et ont fait tour b 4 on donne la tour
alors avec l'idée de faire tour à quatre
tours a aidé le pion à pour qu'il avance
car par exemple comme ça
voilà du coup les deux pions avancerait
je monte ça rapidement et si la tour est
prise on fait à 4 si on pousse pas
prendre et on va pousser nos pions et
gagner la partie avec les cations passé
yes petit truc rapide l'histoire de
petit plus pour nîmes jovovich gentil ça
incroyable ouais classique mais
important moi mais de toute façon oui
c'est qu'ils vont dans des structures de
plein blocs est à des thèmes comme ça
alors le truc le plus classique c'est
évidemment un sacrifice de pièces contre
deux points d'une chaîne
oui voilà mais après tu as d'autres
possibilités après évidemment aussi de
grands classiques c'est quand un pion
agissent versus un pion h7 est pas tu
fais tout pour forcer un petit poisson
ne vous projet 6 ou d'écaillage 4 qui
prend g6 pour pousser de pioche quoi
voilà mais là c'est un peu différent
c'est un peu moins moins triviale mais
bon le plan reste le même et donc ça va
reprendre je crois entre les deux
oiseaux ou pas encore ça devrait leur
excellente question de bas qui est ce
que très haut blanc c'est nul les si oui
comment ça m'étonnerait pas ce que je
vois à foix 3 nuls oui bah oui il faut à
trois je pensais nul non je suis pas sûr
de tout ce soit nul 1
parce que là même si tu joues le retour
des quatre peut-être maintenant mais
mais tu peux te prendre des zones là par
exemple je vous fous ces 8 4 ouais je
veux faire quoi j'ai juste fait rage et
de roi non mais moi je veux des tours à
sept trous béants b2i mais surtout
rachète sur les tours bien oui la b2
mais perd la dir est j'analyse alors dit
quand je fais la vidéo ce truc la finul
ouais patiente dans toutes les
situations
moi je pense que mathieu est ce que roy
b 5 3 à 4 et tourbe et katz ap le marché
balawi forcément mais après rob est sain
de talent est tombé 1 maintenant est-ce
que forcément non la tombe d'un rabbin
cinq tours b bon après tu encore b2 mais
après j'ai un peu peur que tu te fasses
planté life 5 ha ouais chose comme ça
bref la question bête de baky il a
canalisé chiffres y voit et il me
donnerait comme exercice il veut je ne
résoudrai pas il est terrible se bat qui
intime entre un truc pour rigoler un
truc un peu marrant et tout dit mme tu
prends un exercice dans la gueule je
comprends pas je reste jamais rien si tu
commences à résoudre c'est fini oui tu
as bien raison il faut pas encourager
les comportements des gens ah oui là
c'est ça peut être une arrestation
direct s'il passe la frontière est
numéro 1 quête il ya foule et de tawke
race qui estimera honte terrible
après il ya p2 peut-être ouais mais mais
j'ai peut-être passion qu'est ce que tu
attends tu joues f5 mans bref voilà bah
qui s c'est beaucoup mieux badens moi je
montrais juste ça histoire de rigoler de
minutes de montrer un petit peu et
meublés et tabac qui dans le chat qui te
qui commence à poser des questions quoi
c'est pas possible et ce qui joue ben
moi je les vois pas reprend à ça et ça
vient de reprendre sa partie
c'est parti et pas un petit change
d'ouverture parce que ça va lui réussir
magnus qui est un peu nonchalant à la
cam pas facile aussi à gérer quand tu
mènes d'autant de points que tu as
autant de temps de jeu qui reste tu peux
te déconcentrer un mois mais là il va je
pense que la suisse y va plus se
dérouler je pense que je pense que là
par hamid a pris un coup de bambou parce
qu il ait eu des occases
mine de rien est clairement moins 2 ou
moins ça aurait pas été menées de mener
d'un point ou deux ça n'aurait pas été
volé à la haye travail je pense monnaie
de quatre points c'est vraiment le
scénario qatar pour lui et ses
présidents linverse de ton match à toi
hier par exemple ou sarine j'ai
l'impression qu'il a eu le meilleur
scénario quoi ouais alors pas
complètement parce qu'il ya des partis
forcément où ça s'est pas mal goupillé
pour moi mais oui en moyenne on va dire
que enfin le plus c'est qu'au final est
logique quoi alors que la part âme celle
inverse donc déjà champion du monde il a
des problèmes de connexion et en plus il
a le mauvais scénario quoi ça fait
beaucoup pour un seul homme
c'est ça
[Musique]
donc pourquoi ça arrive brutalement
lentement ça tient peu répondu maxime
tout à l'heure parce qu'il était en
difficulté face à dans ses positions
ouais en fait le truc c'est difficile de
jouer vite si tu te sens pas en
confiance dans les positions s'il ya
quelque chose qui ne plaît pas tout de
suite tu vas chercher à résoudre
et comme tu vas pas trouvé qu'en
immédiatement comment résoudre tu veux
en berge et tu perds du temps
bon après j'ai vu que ça t'arrive aussi
kevin tu récupères elle est souvent tu
es une minute en retard parce que tu
aimes pas la position où tu prends ton
temps pour calculer des trucs mais c'est
un défaut je dirais voilà mais après
ouais comme sarine tu es une bonne
pointe de vitesse à la fin il est celle
qui a permis de tenir de trois positions
avec peu de temps à l'afp anjela non moi
j'aime bien jouer lentement 800 mhz et
en partie donc je vous lentement aussi
en fait d'ailleurs
ouais moi c'est la nasa tu joue vite les
gendarmes sont étonnés quand je joue en
partie longue des rares fois où je
jouais il pense que je vais peut
réfléchir et je suis content parce que
je lis beaucoup en fait celle inverse je
suis plus beau mais souvent baghriche au
coeur d'un conflit seraient pour le coup
triple champion du monde de patin qui
est en fait qu elle faisait un sarine et
couple fait mal celle là je la valide
quand même cela valide quand même je
suis premier a321 waltz je valide cette
penny lane qui va du gange je réfléchis
trop longtemps gc tu vois aujourd'hui
j'ai pensé à tes conseils dire
j'essaye de jouer un peu plus vite
contre l'arménie ouais mais tu vois je
suis les conseils du patron mais oui
après que ça arrive normalement ils
jouent beaucoup plus vite que ça c'est
juste les circonstances de match et les
positions qu'ils obtenaient qu'il n'y
avait pas mais je crois que normalement
ils jouent beaucoup plus que ça si tu
sais tu sais quand speech et c'était la
même chose en juniors et c'est juste à
il est l un à l état à ceylan est ok
j'ai rien dit s'il était lent il était
là j'ai été surpris aussi en fait parce
qu'après je suis particulièrement rapide
c'est sept jours c'est dur d'appui
autant contre moi ça pour le coup il ya
que nakheel qui arrivent à nantes était
dure à jouer mais tu es encore plus durs
à jouer sur un vrai échec sur internet
atari je met une énorme pression donc
changer de boulot ça va là pour parham
web à double double au champ de kétou
qui se passe pas mal là va falloir
commencer à demander même plus comment
tu développes m'amuse très mal autant
bon je vais pas faire de pronostic
tester chaque fois je suis un pronostic
[Musique]
l'inversé se produit pas si je vais
faire un pronostic mais new skies cette
partie bien sûr tu la gagnes pas si tu
alors que c'est la seule qui vaille à
lui et qui humanise va gagner mais c'est
dû porter la poisse kavanagh fils
logique 1 pour pouvoir développer le
foie fuite
on est dans le très logique
wolman broad tu vois on dit que on
demande si les juges qu'ils sont
normalisées en tournoi je crois qu'il ya
plusieurs types des fichiers qui sont
possible d'utiliser mais après on joue
pas toujours sur les mêmes défis qui est
même rare mois mais les pièces les
pièces sont normalisés par contre oui
mais la taille et le poids non au et de
la taille elle aux toiles on met la
forme des pièces
est ce que à ton niveau le niveau de jeu
de carlson t'impressionne maxime abat
son meilleur niveau oui mais bon après
on avait moyen de faire face quand même
un peu ouais c'était pas si loin c'est
pas si loin mais après c'est vrai que
l'écart est plus dur à combler
ah bah oui plus tu montes au plus les
plus les centres à gravir son du rhin
c'est un peu comme les vrais ça va comme
le saut à la perche
oui après si tu as une grande perche ça
peut ça peut l'aider quoi on écouta
meuse est est ce que dame b 4 peut être
une idée ici genre pour échanger les
dames et les vices et leurs 2 on a par
am qui a pris trop de temps qu'ils aient
changé les fous de cases noires chez pas
émis vers même se retrouver moins bien
en al ala sayej nos commentaires sont
pris pour des du tendance mais c'est pas
mal là par contre le vih 1 qui a enfermé
mais oui c'est planter car les haïtiens
qui avaient bloqué la sellette avantage
blanc parce que sur m6 tu auras toujours
le match 4
elkayam ne revient plus jamais en jeu il
devrait la gagner par am du coup après
les deux joueurs n'ont plus de temps là
il va jouer tour b 1
alors est-ce qu'il peut jouer qu'à
peut-être des 4,5 ou mais il veut donner
deux d'abord une emprise de maintien
dans le sien c'est en achetant ce tour
c'est trois gymnases des 4 way est
maintenant tour c'est un pur c5 puis on
prend bon bah ça va jouer là faut pas
que la connexion des rails pour 7,5
partie à 5 qui veut tout français 6 mais
je suis fatigué il ya des mecs de
diamètre
mais la dual carrier qui jouent non
ouais autolia kg 3 enfin c'est chaud
ouais c'est bouillant où là j'ai pas du
tout aimé un fou d'un y avait 2 mai 5e b
saint quentinois terre ça aussi c'est
ouais ouais je pense qu'ils continuent à
la vie un peu car nf2 ça gagner la dame
qui a raté le match mais
mais il a pris le point et ça fait plus
5 maxime les partis qui suivent et qui
se ressemblent un finalement par am qui
a réussit jamais à conclure et qui petit
à petit sans fond ça ouais bah oui c'est
terriblement battu khoury le bon prono
c'est terrible ah oui c'était écrit
mais c'est bizarre ce qu'il a fait de
laisser la dame on rentrait tout quoi du
coup ça fait cinq français si je n'ai
pas du tout aimé ça c'est au piano qui
je pense que ludique va devoir sévir l'a
pourtant j'aime bien benoît perret son
avocat il federer gaël monfils ça te
convient ah oui bien sûr c'est en plus
kèkè comme au tennis c'est quand même
ultra concurrentiel ouais top 5 ou de
tennis ça peut être l'équivalent de top
2 échecs surtout surtout que gaël il est
tombé quand même sur la génération la
plus forte de tous les temps pour la
peine quand il était numéro 5 il était
derrière federer jo voilà ce nadal
murray
bon oui il n'est pas tombé sur la
génération la plus facile quoi voilà oui
c'est ça c'est une très concurrentiel
pas peut-être les quatre meilleurs
joueurs de tous les temps en tout cas 3
3 qui ont qui ont joué à la même période
c'est quand même impressionnant quand il
pense oui c'est ça son galles s'engager
j'aurais bien aimé faire vite son camp
juste en un style de jeu qui
ressemblerait plus à son grade r ouais
si on comparait les styles puisque
galles c'est plus défensif quand même
oui et jo c'était plus ils envoyaient
quoi ralala les tags qui vont tomber et
là les peines qui vont tomber à tout va
grosjean c'est pas possible
choco et j'ai compris moi j'ai pas
passer mon permis je sais je veux pas
envoyer toutes les toutes les voitures
dans numéro
tu penses passé grosjean du temps
le tennisman sébastien grosjean
non il disait hamilton hamilton approche
nous rejoint d'accord d'accord j'ai raté
le message c'est un gros gens c'était
gros joueurs ah oui bien sûr beau coup
droit
c'est terrible
le chat imt robe le chat qui ne méritent
pas vcj simon est joué pas mal ici mon
père oui c'est un bon joueur mais bon
mdr sébastien grosjean bas c'était un
gros joueur sébastien grosjean quand
même il a bah oui c'est un gros joueur
elle après raster il a dû faire demi
finales après c'était une génération
moins concurrentiels quoi c'est par
rapport à tout ce qui se prennent avec
son galets mon fils il a moins de mérite
on n'est moins sûr du mérite de
sébastien grosjean
mais c'est un gros joueurs comme cédric
pioline et oui guy forget extraordinaire
après ouais j'ai eu six mois était top 6
mondial mais par rapport à un monfils et
tsonga lui l'a clairement complètement
optimiser son potentiel son game en fils
ans n'est pas complètement sûr qu'ils
auraient pas pu faire mieux
après ils ont là où ils sont allés c'est
quand même très très bon déjà on n'est
pas en est moins sûr est ce que les
matchs donc en cinq sets
mais ouais mais jgc sivement il sait
très bien que 6e en 10 ans c'est déjà un
miracle mais c'est très beau c'est beau
sixième mondial c'est beau quand tu y
penses
après je pense que tsonga mine de rien
la finale perdue contre djoko s'il la
gagne à la case aujourd'hui peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui bangoura il n'aurait pas
dit grand chelem mais il pourrait en
avoir 3 4 facile je pense songa quand tu
revois les moments forts de sa carrière
et les gros matches qui leur est il
était impressionnant un impressionnant
c'est la cata gasquet aussi d'heure qui
a été très très bon
huawei mais qui a été trop attendu trop
jeune c'est dur ça attention celui qui a
le plus maximiser sa carrière par
rapport au talent à son talent au tennis
bon à part les grosses et wawrinka
à l'inter il a maximisé de ouf
ouais mais alors africa le truc c'est
que il a la capacité d'être un joueur
oui c'est ça donc cette course comme ça
qu'ils optimisent est après celui qui a
malheureusement absolument pas optimisé
mais là pour le coup c'est des
circonstances extérieures s'est-elle
potro lui s'il n'est pas blessé il peut
être a dit grand chelem aujourd'hui
oui je pense que c'est impossible à mes
oreilles pas du tout mais vrai il ya une
très belle carrière oui il a une
blessure à la fin mais bon il a
tellement fort c'est tellement usé ned
potro c'est bien pire
s'il y arrive et c'est parfois exagéré
mais il est tellement stru del potro un
sens parce que maintenant on sait enfin
s'ils arrivent à faire alors qui peut
plus faire un revers à demain
il est obligé de se lasser tout serveur
c'est quand même c'est quand même
impressionnant
non c'est terrible c'est terrible del
potro s'était arrimé bon là après c'est
un peu comme ce que je disais tout à
l'heure par rapport à la semoule quoi
après ça rentre en compte aussi à la
capacité à bien sûr oui bah et poignées
en carton c'est poignant carton mais
mais c'est quand même pas de chance
c'est pas du français c'est pas de
chance non del potro bondi grand chelem
c'est peut-être beaucoup même passion
parce que enfin il est capable de jouer
à un niveau où il est injouable
donc à partir de l'homme il ya l us open
avant ces grosses blessures je crois
quand même
en 2009 c'est après qu'il a vraiment
commencé à avoir un bon alors là il s'en
sort pas mal
en tout cas un coup dans sa note et je
dois dire que j'ai un peu lâché mais
mais oui on va dire que il là il a des
petites chances la tour 4 ya peut-être
des cinq qui gagne et ouais y'a 6 g qui
a mis un message intéressant oui à la
voile et f3 aussi mais fois ci c'est
peut-être mieux qui dit que del potro
gagne sur le fait qu' il n'y a pas pas
tant joueurs que ça qui en son profil et
du coup les gens en plus de mal à
s'adapter à mais bon même ça fait aussi
partie des ouais c'est comme dire que
nadal a la chance de les juger ou je
sais pas quoi voilà deux d'avoir se bat
nadal c'est le seul à avoir ce profil
sur terre battue calendrier fixé sais
pas si tu te rappelles ce joueur ouais
mais bon même qu'ils étaient dangereux
il va labourer same way i like ça se
voit qu'il l'a eu et sûr en fait il la
gaine nathan s'est pas fait encore robin
wales à gré willem de l'agur à coup tu
cherches quand même ouais vers magnus
pas content encore oui mais bon c'est
sûr que connaissant magnus gagner sur le
lac plusieurs partis ça fait pas plaisir
ouais mais tu as ya peut-être deux vins
peut-être sans le lac déjà yahia il ya 6
4 et 6 1 ouais ce qu'il en a quand même
perdu plusieurs sur lag huawei et là il
ya 6 30 des cas c'est terrible bienvenue
dans ma life de commentateurs de
speechless maxime est oui ah bah ouais
c'est celle au t1 pour les prochaines
fois
ici la prochaine fois vis ma vie quoi en
fait dans un épisode de vis ma vie quoi
c'est fantastique
nadal n'est pas gauche afin qu'elle a
travaillé de trois gauchers au tennis je
pensais pas le niveau était si resserré
entre 26 70 c 28 81
si citoyen mais pas sur quoi sur une
partie est bien sûr que le niveau est
resserrée fait c'est très peu énorme à
la fois en fait c'est pas énorme dans le
sens où si tu veux une partie ouais
c'est pas énorme mais pour combler cette
différence là de la quantité de travail
lé voilà c'est astronomiques
oui oui et puis en plus par an mais
particulièrement fort en glisse c'est
pas 26,70 santé c'est yann il a raison
elle serait plus 27 15 27 20 ans
ouais au moins 27 points ouais ouais la
lasser ces dommages là c'est juste toi
le tarif est très très élevé pour
prendre une image assez claire
ouais après comme on a dit à l'ats la
connexion ça joue aussi et c'est vrai
que si tu comptes le champion du monde
était déjà pas à 100% de serpents
cependant les partis fin c'est pas
possible à un moment donné ouais ouais
ouais bah là je pense qu'il va lâcher la
balle à il a déjà lâché non ouais bah
non je l'apprécié la dernière regarde la
dernière il a fait il a gagné
oui oui mais bon c'est qu'il a perdu le
match qu'il a perdu match nul ici par am
gagner cette prochaine il repasse devant
tout est possible bhatti qui ai dit tu
me mets face à man must c'est pas la
même non parce que tu sera préparée face
à manu si magnus n'est pas préparé pour
jeu comme toi elle est sacrément dur à
jouer ce pack du son en tout cas alors
oui mais la wii et enfin par exemple qui
3 pas se permettre de jeu comme ça le
seul contre artémias non contraignant
qui peut pas - jouera pas comme ça
contre les gens pas comme ça mais ça se
voit qu'il est pas content
magnus il avait battu lille avait battu
sont joints f3 à f2 mais ça ça veut rien
dire
non bien sûr mais bon il a aussi perdu
contre un nid chamboule est alors que
annie celle des jo avec trente secondes
contre une minute
oui non c'est vrai aussi fait ouais le
boulet ses beats et des quatorze
tellement spécial que tu which finale
mais faire tu peux te permettre de faire
n'importe quoi pas sur un match mais sur
une partie clairement
regarde moi j'ai bien fait contre manu
sans une grob
voilà un exemple j'y pense et plus je
savais que c'est un bon exemple
ça veut pas dire une grand chose bon là
je sais pas ce qui fait pas mal à celle
là elle va faire très mal
là il a rangé ses pièces ouais on n'est
pas en 960 parole sinon kg 3 qui est à
chaque 8 nt1 cette tête est envisageable
mais ils jouent plus très bien ouais
mais je pense que là ça fait trop mal je
veux pas tu peux pas rester dans le
match dans ces conditions ans est là
c'est pas possible
et en plus je peux parise aïn bah ouais
condamné condamné à jouer mais ça c'est
vrai que ça fait mal hein ne fait pas
foi rizaï mois pour cette raison là tu
vois tu me demanderais de vouloir jouer
un speech est contre magnus je pense que
je refuserais en fait par la peur de ce
truc là en fait à un moment donné
prendre 30 0 enfin pourtant à marche le
plus joué et obligé de rester assis de
jouer c'est insupportable en fait
nouveau l'angola s'est déjà
insupportable pour nous alors pour ouais
pas ramasser ses katas
ouais et puis là on voit bien comme voit
la différence d'activité des pièces
n'est même pas besoin de jouer aux
échecs pour voir la différence quand on
voit la crypte les noirs sont bien bien
plus avancés sur l'échiquier là par
l'exemple du g6 âge s'en cachent quatre
pour être bien sûr que que les pièces
d'or soit le plus loin possible et j'ai
6 ans voit ça à l'air pas mal parce que
sur foot franchise tv g5 et tu peux rien
faire je suis preneuse 5 à 4 aux deux
prochains coups davantage que ça va pas
disparaître
c'est terrible pour par am
après il ya le truc aussi de savoir à
quel moment tu perds mathématiquement le
match nantes intérêt mais des fois on
essaye de tu vois ouais là on est où il
reste chez jean leurs deux matchs à
peut-être il ya notre module est quoi
donc peut-être avant de boulettes quoi
ça c'est pas possible c'est bien
possible a battu voilà il l'a pas très
bien négocié magnus oui parce qu'il peut
pas bouger le cavalier il ya dame
problème si skype 5 ha ouais il a même
très très mal égoïste je bougeais les
les jambes je crois que c'est le ventilo
de l'ordi
ah oui alors dit c'est vrai c'est pas
méchant
ah oui gagner salle apparemment a pour
le coup oui c'est pas impossible mais tu
as c'est aussi ça ok si elle peut aussi
se prend rémy sait même pas c'était un
mystique en fait
ouais c'est dur c'est frustrant
bon alors si maintenant il ya un enjeu
pour parham parce que manu c'est au
dessus des 3950 il faut changer cet état
de fait absolument c'est hype à ce qu'en
fait tu vois tu vois magnus qui en a
marre tu voyais pas ram qui en a marre
ouais ça fait tellement aucun sens en
fait là c'est ça en fait ouais c'est les
trois heures qui viennent du coup au
fait c'est dans ces moments là le format
3 heures et pas du tout adapté c'est
pour ça que ça va pas parce que par
exemple tu peux faire un match premier
as tu peux faire un match en plusieurs
sets gagnants mais là qu'est ce que tu
veux faire tu sais que tu as encore une
heure de jeu quoi annoncer c'est
vraiment le gros problème est vraiment
un pour les gens qui sont nouveaux c'est
pas ça fait six parties de suite il perd
plus de mon souvent avec des des
horreurs à la fin non mais en fait c'est
pas parce que il gagne si facilement que
ça le fait chier parce que parce que là
le match est plus grand intérêt qu'il
n'a pas bien joué par ailleurs qu' il
doit en gros son score aux a pas mal de
circonstances extérieures
évidemment il est plus fort évidemment
il sera en tête mais mais du coup on
perd tout l'enjeu du match bêtement quoi
oui oui alors qu'un système de cette
taille aurait 2 sets 0 2 0 dans le
dernier set en trois gagnants ou en cas
d'urgence à rien mais bon je suis mal lu
6 ans ou d'adopter par homme qu enfin je
veux dire c'est pas son objectif de
vielles quoi ça se voit d'ailleurs je te
remets la cam parce que je savais que tu
l'as pas wen en grand ouais il en a ils
s'emmerdent largement
ils s'emmerdent eux mêmes très largement
ça se comprend un mélange et c'est ce
que j'arrive germain comprendre c'est
comment ça n'a pas changé depuis des
années alors que tu as le public qui
s'emmerdent et gens qui commentent qui
joue et ça vient vraiment uniquement due
forme à quoi c'est dommage ah oui moi
j'espère un match tendu mais on a eu
notre première heure ce qui était très
tendue mais on a eu au moins ça imagine
si ça commence à cannes 0 ça m'est déjà
arrivé plus d'une fois
ouais c'est terrible il m'arrivait un
match je me rappelle un dépôt car yaqub
way qui s'annonçait bien et ça commence
à 9,1 pour carrier hakim que veux tu
faire annoncer vos c'est vraiment
vraiment dommage ça c'est dommage que
ces problèmes récurrents et on se
retrouve toujours aux mêmes trucs et du
cou à force d'en faire en prêtent à une
petite appréhension avant le début du
match en disant pourvu que ça tourne pas
comme ça ouais mais du coup on a eu du
bol quand on est fière avec ton match on
a eu de la chance que c'était un beau
match
waouh c'est resté c'est resté serré
jusqu'au bout quoi bien sûr
en foot c'est différent à ivo karlovic
parce que c'est un sport avec un
comptage complètement différent si tu
mets des buts mais il peut y en avoir
zéro koala les parties à l'essentiel
c'est comme au tennis tu as forcément
résultat après un point quoi ou
attention au foot de toute façon par un
temps de jeu beaucoup plus limité en
plus oui mais ça joue une heure trente
est pas 3h30 oui au tennis est différent
mais moi c'est un format 7
mais en fait c'est je peux pas comparer
des trucs où il ya du fait que par
exemple la non ce match je suis sûr qu'à
un moment on pourrait se dire que parent
pourra gagner les cinq dernières parties
et perdre le match
au tennis c'est pas possible oui si tu
gagnes le dernier point sauf cas
d'abandon que tu as gagné le match donc
mais qui peut tout en revenir alors que
là c'est un moment donné tu peux plus
quoi bon après ça c'est en théorie ce
qui évidemment sur un 3 sets gagnants tu
es mené deux sets à un break comme nadal
encore que medvedev a failli faire l us
open 2e set un break je veux bien dire
que vraiment il ya enfin même si ça
arrivera une fois sur cent mille
ça peut arriver cette rampe beckett
j'aime passer 32,4 j'ai pas compris on
me dit sur un psg mousse conclure 88 oui
mais bon enfin en fait là on parle c'est
l'équivalent d'un huitième de finale de
ligue des champions voilà je ne peux pas
comparer sa non c'est clairement un
énorme problème de format de toute façon
c'est on est le seul sport qui est
pratique ce format oui ah oui non ça ça
peut pas exister dans un truc de
comptage comme ça ça existe nulle part
ailleurs
pas le truc des 17 il y avait il y avait
deux problèmes déjà le problème c'est
qu'on n'était pas bien sûr que ce soit
le meilleur qui gagne parce que ce
qu'ont expliqué tout à l'heure il avait
pas parce que du coup il peut y avoir
une partie à 2-2 pour gagner un set j'ai
mis les sept ans 3 qui est plus
importante qu'une partie à 0 0 donc il
n'aimait pas trop le fait que que ça ça
ça rende enfin que l'un joueurs moins
forts puisse voler un set ou quoi il
n'aimait pas trop enfin il y avait un
îlot singulier qui n'aimait pas trop
et aussi le fait de pas avoir un temps
défini de match en fait il aimait pas
non plus donc moi mon argument c'est
dire oui mais du coup c'est pas défini
parce que quand le match est fini du
coup au lieu de se taper des heures à
regarder un truc qui sert à rien là au
moins j'étais complètement fini mais eux
ils disaient ouais mais du coup bah
c'est pas pratique on peut pas faire
d'horaires et moins qu il est moins loin
et moins de pub ouais ouais
du coup pour les matches passent et
moins de pub mais à moi enfin moi je
trouve que c'est la logique face je
trouve c'est une logique bizarre en fait
pascal ma ferme c'est un forme
intéressante à plus de gens qui
regarderont mais voilà en gros
bien sûr bon il a fait une bonne
position mais là et qui va pas gagner
notre petit forum sans doute tenir ça
nul mais bon encore faut-il ne pas
tomber autant mais c'est vrai que là
c'est dur quoi on est à on a essayé
d'évaluer si les îles à perdre autant ou
s'il va tenir
bref voilà pour le petit piège avec la
fourchette mais il veut que je reste ici
avait assiste donc c'était en août
petits pièges l'attenté de prêt à y
retourner si c'était une chèque tomber
si cela comprend plus 8 e
égayez y est il nous reste combien de
temps un corps à une demi heure j'aime
pas cet argument est le meilleur est
celui qui gagne c'est pas le meilleur
qui doit gagner
j'ai pas envie de leur idée c'est que si
ça dure très longtemps et qui a
énormément de partie et que c'est un
système de comptage comme ça fait
forcément le plus fort qui gagne à la
fin
ouais bah après pour le coup au tennis
en grand chelem c'est un peu comme ça
que ça marche
trois sets gagnants avait même parfois
au début le cinquième c'est peut-être un
tie break pour éviter que des karlovic
puis c'est trop dangereux
oui voilà mai mais bon même comme ça
après le fait qu'ils aient le comptage
17 change tout parce que je suis sûr par
contre que si tu fais des matches de
tennis
on va dire où tu fais des comptages de
points donc genre promis à premier à 100
points dans le match je pense que là il
ya tout en gardant le format des jeux de
service etc
enfin tu fais par exemple d'un super
tie-break deux premiers à 100 je pense
que c'est un massacre
oui oui c'est encore prêt mais en fait
du coup la logique du tennis et des
sports comme ça c'est aussi de se dire
linverse c'est un format qui peut
favoriser quelqu'un qui peut bien se
mobiliser sur une partie ou quoi en fait
c'est ça et favoriser aussi entre
guillemets le
la plage orange ont joué j'ai trois
peut-être alors fallait voir qu'edf 4
mais j'ai trois ans ça me semble
intéressant c'était pas je vous prends
je croyais dames 35 après ouais parce
que là j'ai peur que tu as ta pas le
temps je le sais quel point ces 5 et du
coup il ya des no 5 qui va arriver on
était tennis et un format qui favorise
le suspense et le spectacle sur thouet
mais en fait
du coup ça favorise tout parce que quand
tu es je dirais alors pour le suspense
si je tirais surtout sur deux sets
gagnants
bien sûr trois sets gagnants bon il y a
des surprises en grand chelem mais c'est
un même club
c'est plus et à la forme tête et une
petite blessure que tu connais pas enfin
toi quand tu es spoliateurs tu sait pas
qu'il est blessé vous quoi oui ou alors
après tu avais un autre format pour ça
mais ça a été je n'avais pas proposé
mais ce serait de faire un chaos genre à
un moment donné tu gagnes 5 tu laisses
ce format là mais cela n'importe quel
moment dans le match tu fais cinq
victoires d'affilée et a gagné le match
par ko pour garder le truc du temps un
peu comme à la boxe quoi du coup à
donner la possibilité de faire un cadeau
à n'importe quel moment
ouais - quelque part la magnus il serait
motivée pour mettre 5 et pour finir et
si parra me survit peser rabat en bullet
si ça tourne bien je lui mets un cas où
ce serait déjà fini
oui là ce serait déjà fini mais tu vois
pour les matchs où quelqu'un tient il
gagne quatre parties loti sauve encore
ça nul histoire
non mais je suis moins fan non mais je
suis pas fan non tu vois l'idée c'est
pour essayer de garder un semblant de
quelque chose parce que là on fait sinon
c'est ça sert à rien pour personne en
fait ouais bah c'est une torture
psychologique est un vrai la pop trop
gagner des 1000 points pour augmenter sa
part de prize pool quoi mais bon il s'en
fout bref moi je connais par anne il est
comme moi ça il s'en fout
je pense la plupart des joueurs n'ont
d'ailleurs way des comptes d'apothicaire
là ok si ça a joué deux mille euros le
demi point où quoi peut-être c'est
différent oui bien sûr mais auxquels
s'ajoutent 50 euros le demi point où
même pas peut-être 25
je n'ai pas la chance j'ai récupéré 25
euros maintenant non et c'est pas un
supplice simple commentaire est juste
content à la honte les schistes là où
comme inclut le tournoi coiffant comment
q les parties parce que jusqu'en turquie
attend entre nous et on discute ça on en
a jamais vraiment parlé avec maxime due
forme en a jamais eu l'occasion c'est
intéressant d'avoir l'avis de quelqu'un
qui joue en plus ouais bah oui c'est dur
de se dire d'être enthousiaste au point
commenté les parties maintenant j'essaye
un peu en passant nettement le problème
c'est que on sait que même si par am
c'est une série de quatre victoires
il sera encore menés de quatre points
voilà et faire une série de 15 victoires
c'est une chance sur dix heureux
ouais c'est ça annoncée c'est terrible
c'est terrible mais ouais on est en plus
soit excellent bon là cette année
j'espère qu'il y aura moins de moins de
scénarios comme ça après le wpt est là
c'est vraiment spécial parce que je
pense que les circonstances extérieures
enjoué mais sinon le le plateau est
quand même très fort et très très
homogène pour le coup ouais ben mercredi
par exemple fil rouge à
fait 2 cf ça peut être intéressant oh
ben ça va être un très gros match
d'ailleurs ses deux sièges on n'a pas
compté mais c'est un très fort joueur de
parti pris mais qui à un moment donné a
menacé un de d'arriver au dessus de 1720
2730 et puis finalement il a wave est un
peu léger pour pour les partis dans ce
noble et il est sain c'est un mec
sérieux ça va être intéressant bon après
le match qui va être très très compliqué
à suivre c'est martirossian contre naka
mais bon après on sait jamais la force
de l'arménie et la force collective de
l'arménie bah oui mais je pense à finale
depuis on doit gagner mais bon je suis
pas sur sa passion à ses tu joues à cinq
je joue à 5 à 4 à 5 des coûts ça gagne
facilement cinq ans et d ici c'est tu as
beau champion ça va faire plus neuf
jeune âge en effet non mais là c'est
même pour par am c'est quasi triste quoi
cette pagaille et résistance
c'est juste triste ouais alors après
manu c'est un peu merdé mais s'avère
unique et facile non non non non tu vas
voir ce qui se passe c'est peut-être
mieux tu acquiers 4,5
ouais
après t'as vu c'est qu'à 3 des 4 c3 je
pense que j'étais en train de regarder
aussi dans le bon tempo il faut le faire
maintenant
ouais mais c'est même pas sûr parce
qu'il a fait huit attaques sur le congé
6 mais ça doit gagner ou normalement ces
cases elle pas dans les temps c'est pas
du tout dans les temps calcul koala
d'ailleurs bike et pull saïfi que notre
époque dans des temps si vous voulez
être bien sûr ouais il en est bien loin
le temps où twilight en saas ou un temps
comme je trouve c'est tellement visuel
que tu y arrivera en premier
ouais mais ça sur un an mais oui c'est
visuel bien sûr là c'est fini la dame
rachid qui bloque tout et ça fait plus
9a il nous faudra une petite victoire du
pour faire redescendre magnus en dessous
des 3150
mais javier trop sûr mais comment il
s'est qualifié il s'est caché avec les
title tuesday je crois par ham wayne on
est pour le coup c'est un très bon
joueur de ville sympa voilà il tomba il
tombe sur le go atteint way qui encore
une fois est lisse et démotivés là c'est
sûr que ça là bas il sérieux de gueule
il tient une gueule de quelqu'un qui a
envie de se barrer
dalia un petit conseil que je peux lui
faire ce qu'ils veulent il ya jamais
personne qui l'a fait mais ça m'étonne
en fait sur le nombre de matchs de ce
pitch assez récents qui n'est jamais un
qui a un jour soit juste levé partie
cohésion va vouloir fait pour toutes les
parties qui viennent et basta après il
peut perdre son presse poule b puis
voilà ouais mais il sera plus invité
machin et tout ça c'est surtout ça
il faut car lotus qui dirait j'ai dit on
dirait mvele dans un mauvais rancart est
ce que je me suis déjà fait autant fier
que ça dans un cas quand même ça non non
ça arrive non ça arrive de se faire
chier nassau les poireaux temps c'est
vrai que ça fait une sacré prochain
quand même si en plus c'est un mec
joyeux la bascule l'air d'être une crème
ouais ah si j'étais lui je me commandera
un bon gros mc do là invaincu peritz à
la pause et du gouffre et pendant le
match on choisit tout de suite sans je
pense à autre chose ouais qui se
présentent à bakar scène ça peut s'il a
un bel et l'eau ça peut être agréable de
jouer un ça peut donner envie
ouais ça te donne envie de se qualifier
en demi-finale ce qu'un règlement
autorise à manger pendant le match
alors si maxime cas pour répondre mais
j'imagine que oui alors dans certains
cas ces interviews manger dans
l'échiquier
enfin on parle en match ici ou là les
deux du cours et pour oddo question ici
pas du tout tu as droit de manche et un
match où tu fais ce que tu veux
d'ailleurs magnus le fait mais alors
pendant les parties
il ya intérêt le monde qui disent du
sein ça peut être interdit devant
l'échiquier surtout notamment quand
c'est à ton adversaire 2 jaunes mais
après c'est complètement autorisé de se
restaurer dans une salle prévue à cet
effet et c'est tu joues des partis qui
peuvent durer jusqu'à six heures
heureusement que tout droit de mon
charme quand jusqu'à cette heure même un
bon gros kebab quoi
c'est à dire arriver un émail mais on
demande qui tu joues au prochain tour
donc c'est le vainqueur de nespouls
onion voilà c'est ça si le monde est
celle qui tombe dans les mains ça c'est
pas un mauvais tirage ans dans les deux
cas ce que par homme va stopper
l'hémorragie interne lie plats halal peu
vrai mais en plus je joue souvent voit
bien que ma nièce vous pas du tout à son
maximum là bas forcément il a dit c'est
qu'il a gagné le match
du coup à partir de là quand tu es
compétiteur et c'est là que toute la
différence se fait avec le tennis au
tennis pourquoi nadal il continue à être
à fond plus ou moins fous on va dire
vont peut-être qu'il va arrêter de break
à son adversaire mais il va quand même
jouer à fond et encore pas sur un des
capable de continuer a breaké son
adversaire dès ce qu il sait qu'il doit
gagner le dernier point du match et du
coup ne peut pas se démobiliser la
magnus
s'il fait pas n'importe quoi il va
pouvoir arriver en boulettes et perd
toutes ses parties boulettes et gagner
le match quoi c'est un vrai problème ça
comme ça un vrai problème de la vie bref
quoiqu'il arrive vrai oui oui non mais
après après ils sont tous comme ça il a
je lâche pas il ne lâche pas des jeux
pour rien voilà
mais c'est aussi une errance en c'est
inhérent au système de comptage
c'est à dire que si nadal tu lui dis que
là bas il peut perdre les vingt derniers
points du match
bon bah il va peut-être perdre les vingt
derniers points du match
oui bah oui mais c'est normal c'est
humain
tu peux pas rester c'est tellement dur
de faire de la compétition ça demande
tellement que que tu peux pas la faire
voilà tu rien car mon niveau ridicule
tout à l'heure quand j'ai dit c'est un
peu en trail hard pendant une heure et
demie la cre avant qu'on commence ça
commence à me filer une petite migraine
quoi tu avais besoin d'un peu souffler
ok
juste si tu sais que tu dois continuer
oui mais c'est comme jérémy dumont
match.com sarine
évidemment j'ai eu des trucs des moments
détente elle devra peut-être des
fourchettes un sens d'ailleurs non
messieurs là pour le coup c'était un
prix move mais enfin tu rates des trucs
très belle temps parlement peut pas
rester là on voit bien que même tenue ce
jour à un niveau inégal aussi ai je un
niveau très inégale si tu dis à mon fils
de gagner 18 points contre maso il va
les gagner avant verra ça ce sera fait
sans doute ça aura lieu il va falloir
qu'il se présente un gaël le match aura
lieu
je pense oui et oui ça va être chaud
puis surtout que en plus faut se dire
que gaël il aura aussi les échecs à
s'occuper entre chaque round et puis ça
peut ça peut pomper de l'énergie mentale
parce qu'il va essayer quand même de
faire durer la partie d'échecs un peu
puis voilà parce que il va pas rester
pendant cinq minutes n'a pas joué un
coup non non il va jouer c'est pas la
mentalité de la maison bah oui bien sûr
alors parade nouvelle défaite ou pas
naturel précieux or noir le une bonne
pause quand il a pas de temps à les
parents ne va gagner celle-là
allez je joue mon pronostic bon je joue
un bon pronostic dans ma vie ça va être
très chaud il ya le carrier qui va
revenir vers des salles et c4 et c4 qui
menace un guide et si c'était un truc en
la salle des fêtes à 17 ans et 5
ayala combine elle marche ou pas bah
ouais parce qu'il faut aussi s'en russie
soit il n'y a pas de date à date et 6
périble mike du sport quand même quand
il s'agit toi ça c'est fort c'est fort
quand même
tu vois là fallait jouer aux dames c'est
un pur avoir d'un mètre quatre échecs
là c'est c'est pas le match mais sega
semble plus trop de temps pour magnus
c'est une pièce c'est terminé c'est
terminé ça fait plus 10 je n'ai pas le
prendre un pronostic juste c'est
terrible à +10 salle est intéressant
parce que will hayes
après on va pouvoir sur motivé je pense
pour les boulettes parce que on verra
peut-être que rome pourra exprimer un
peu son talent et puis hein ça donnera
des parties plus à nu et là bon les 13
prochaines minutes c'est ça fait déjà 25
que c'est une torture quoi c'est dur
c'est dur pour la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'on a un maillot après temps je
vérifie ça maso mazaurette il en train
de dormir
non il y dit justement qui peut pas ce
soir justement il ya un écran il m'a
écrit un message avait pas vu parce que
j'étais en train de stream terrible
terrible donc pas de maso après la sade
est un acquis qui va se présenter
j'écris
ah là là tu tentes le bar sauvage jeux
sont un maquis sauvage non pas les 3150
après trois heures de ce pitch n'est pas
la peine d'être tentée les 2950 tu peux
me mettre une corde aussi corps
partisane que la balle de match était
relativement serré et puis mais tout a
été relatif à ce que là ça fait neuf
parties c'est la partie de l'adoption
j'écris j'écris au maquis sauvage ce qui
est dans le tchad encore bas qu'ils
étaient par exemple je suis sûr que même
s'ils jouent à fologo qui n'a rien à
voir avec les échecs fred et foncez ah
ouais mais c'est à non mais c'est à
dessein que c'est un bon coup tu vois là
peut-être est-ce que par am peut gagner
cette partie peut-être qualtrough
charcuterie par contre les gars là une
question que je me pose est ce qu'on est
bien sûr que bynum a été plus fort non
il est moins bien en fait peut-être puis
on prend vous prend et fou à 3 pour
tenter un truc
ouais nan fois trop c'est rien c'est moi
c'est détriment tu paries sur quoi tu
bats qui suit paris sur un bas qui sauva
joue pas à je le vois bien de bikey
sauvage ray je me sens bien baky sauvage
on sera plus dans deux sphères valise
est vraiment plus fort haye avait dame
france 5e 4 qui était mieux pour essayer
donne là le kg devait quand même très
très triste qui se la jouent pas bâti
sauvage mais il a dû ce bar et du live
non il est pas dans la bd partie baki il
ya un bon cru les médias peuvent pas
qu'ils 83 ça va être à manger un ca doit
dîner et sa non moins probable
un prêt de se présenter à tout moment il
ya du fou g4 fait peut arriver à tout
moment pour m'amuser ou deux fois trois
fois je crois ça peut faire mal mais
tactiquement tu vas pouvoir et h 4 way
après je sais pas si j'aurais fait ça je
pense pas que ce soit la meilleure move
pratique mais oui parce que jouer trois
heures de plus
faut faire des prolos en d'autres façons
pauvre parham problème
h4 ça fait ou pas telle qu'ils votent
pour des six sur ça rien ne sait pas ce
qu'il veut moi aussi je sais pas ce que
je vais enfin j'imagine que je sais pas
ce qu'il veut non plus après à ce moment
du match
pas mal joué ouais sous ses yeux et tu
veux quoi je les ai 4 ira prendre des
six non mais oui après tout les joueurs
qui sont pas dans le top ten qui joue
des tournois du top ten c'est rare
qu'ils s'en sortent vraiment bien c'est
sûr mais bon mais là c'est
particulièrement spéciale le format fait
que aussi c'est la grosse fessée
bon bah c'est la cannelle ou et le
gaillard qui qui qui était pas content
parce que je dis que le format était
dure à mazet en début de retransmission
et qu'ils écrit l'aimé bien il est où
est ce qu'il est encore là où est-ce
qu'ils osent si je sais je sais pas
cette fac elle fut son pseudo mais je
crois qu'il est parti du coup alors
qu'il disait que c'était c'est un format
fantasy comme on était sûr que ça joue
longtemps maintenant qu'il est parti du
coup à aa
bah ouais mais au premier tour de roland
nathalie mais 6 0 6 1 6 3 mais ça dure
1h30 alors là où c'est vraiment dur
c'est si ça arrive en finale de grand
chelem et c'est une fois mon
heureusement mais mais ouais ça dure une
heure une heure et demie quoi on va dire
la torture dure une heure et demie là ça
fait plus de deux heures qu'on joue 2h30
quasiment ça continue
ça y est la taupe qui dit qu'il aimait
bien mais bon
non mes bien-aimés format auquel mais
sur ce match c'est dur d mais j'essaye
de vent ici là je commence à divaguer de
la fedis d'affilée ouais ça fait mal il
reste encore une ou deux dans la cadence
13 2 ha oui je pense que le match est
quasi mathématiquement fini du coup je
pense que c'est mathématique way à
supposer que cette partie sur la
dernière je pense que c'est mathématique
parce que 10 points d'écart en boule
elle c'est pas possible de rattraper
enfin en théorie si mais en pratique que
jamais dit partie en boulettes en
pratique ce n'est pas faisable à
l'époque bon j'espère que l'on va
pouvoir se motiver pour les boulettes
qu'on aurenti six feux d'artifices pour
finir 6e ça ça peut arriver j'ai eu
c'est bon bah il va pouvoir revoir à 6
en a on a un enjeu pour cette partie
maintenant un gros enjeu non mais éviter
d'être à 0% sur les trois plus jeunes
mais c'est ce que j'avais ce que je
voulais dire mais c'est un leurre
fanny quoi ouais le fanny tellement pas
ip et parce que j'ai cru au bas qui
serait j'envoie des émeutes et où quoi
il répond pas c'est terrible ah là là
nous nous on est comme les joueurs en
fait on peut pas jeter l'épongé non plus
et ouais non mais après les coulées
c'est sympa tu te rassure comme tu peux
c'est beau hein c'est beau c'est de
l'art elle qu'ils se rassurent pas pas
assez d'expérience en crue
je commençais échec et quand je prends
défaite sur défaite en club comme ce
soir max où je me dis mais pourquoi tu
jouais mais c'est un peu ça c'est dur
calé l'entraînement actuelle avec
l'arrêt des candidats maxime 100% folle
guys ça j'en connaisse la diète 1000%
folcheris non dans la gadoue mon gosse
un très important et mon gosse avec des
gens qualitatif en tension des parties
où l'homme et vous prendre des deux mais
non mais non pas fou prend b2 c'est
terrible ça vous prend b2 je trouve 8
dérive ouais non elle était grosse
partie à longueuil attention on n'a pas
eu aussi mais non se présente quand même
bonjour mon gosse pour toi bon jeu ouais
bah après où je suis pas si bon que ça
au congo somalie
j'ai plus de potentiel pour faire des
master class à a manqué ce cas pour le
gaz apple vient il soit bien tapé le top
1 quand même je le mériterai mais je
suis pas sûre par le prendre ce n'était
pas très loin encore l'autre soir ouais
mais ouais voilà c'est fini un qui prend
il décide t il cet essai 6 d'ailleurs tu
peut même commencer par christelle site
et sadique
après je peux jouer pour prendre cet été
rue était donc fini fini fini
quatre prix terrible c'était 22 et demi
cet ennemi je prends le pronom de chasse
comme ça va être encore pire ainsi
magnus le veut
mais après le veut-il voilà ces pièces
de plus c'est fini ah non là c'est pas
fini là c'est pas film c'est pas fini
puisque les pièces d'un jeu sont mal
placés fo qui a validé deux pays ces
quatre là tout 17 foot b5 c'est pas fini
du tout cette partie pour le coup c'est
très bien retourné par parra mof
il va peut-être l'apprendre salé reste
combien de temps de 16 imagine cette
partie se finit encore dix secondes
avant de tyson
tu sais pour avoir dix minutes puis sept
minutes supplémentaires pour être bien
sûr pour avoir le temps de jeu maximal
bon malheureusement n'y aura pas de
prolongation bon ce match
malheureux quelqu'un qui proposait de
faire un peu des 15 plus 10 après à huy
très important enfin petit on fait deux
heures de 15 pouces 10 donc ces quatre
maintenant ces quatre essais trop je
pense que c'est gagnant pour les noirs
en fait ils appelaient pièce de plus oui
mais de cahiers à 4 ne revient pas en
jeu déjà il ya plus de pièces de pluie
et la différence ensuite
donc on enlève le kenya 4 même si on
peut se dire qu'il peut sacrifier pour
d'options mais même en admettant qu'on
rende le kenya 4 pour le clan bfc ce qui
est quand même le match qu'on puisse
obtenir le foot b5 et largement au
dessus du fou g2 la différence de
sécurité des rois est impressionnante
donc tu vas avoir la compo times sur de
la diagonale qu'ayant j4 alors là il
vient d'empêcher kg 4 mais bon du coup
il s'affaiblit encore le plonger trop
bien faible et c'est donc ça c'est
complètement gagnant malgré la pièce de
plus et malgré l'absence sont à dire
dans un gain tactique direct
après le format du tournoi
il est bien mais pas pour des matches
comme ça en fait pas pour des matches
ils se retrouvent à sens unique
sinon il n'y a pas de problème avec le
format en fait mais oui du coup cette
forme à 17 pour éviter pour éviter ça
ouais ça fait ses preuves de façon
toujours à 17 nous l'a utilisé pour nos
tournois et s'est bien passé un quart
est ouais après le seul truc que dès que
quelqu'un gagne 1,7 à sassari vais
jamais au troisième set
en fin août est si dans la vie de ce
trimestre quel peut-être salle est
souvent mais bon après alors et 6 1 j'ai
cru qu'il attendait le tour n'est plus
bon c'est toujours gagnant pour pas âme
ce serait bien qu'ils la gagnent quand
même il ya mathieu qui était le
troisième set contre robert ouais je le
rappelle dans un match qui était très
intéressant et très serré ghosn
mais oui ça peut arriver que après le
premier le la perte du premier set peut
être dur à encaisser
après c'était aussi on s'habituera slam
à la clé joueurs réussiront à mieux et
oui à bien chaque essai on est fou c'est
6 ok bon bah il a fait une bonne partie
ça peut lui donner du baume au coeur
avant les boulettes
ouais voilà enfin il l'a pas encore
gagnaire qui avait prend des deux rôles
ou un adam détroit c'est relou aussi
c'est contre heureux lula s'est ré relou
d'un brancardier prend à ox ac contre
contre contre hull ou non mais attends
c'est contre eux contre hull ou à cette
terre il ya d'albert le même bien tour
eux deux a assez bien joué mais bon du
coup il va pas la gagner je pense ça à
cerner à 5
ok ça c'est bon on est une petite
séquence sympa enfin enfin il est
dégoûté à et rigole mais débutant ouais
ouais ouais terrible à quel point aussi
ça doit faire miel saint paul 4 2 il va
pas faire une fille rouge à hasnon il le
travail est en traitement ou là ça gagne
pas ça non ça devienne pas mais faut je
ne décide pas aussi connaissance revenir
le petit piège de marloux
et il va sauver la nul voila il est tout
sourire elle est tout sourire aura au
moins fait plaisir de le voir sourire
bon ah bon on a eu c'est un sympa au
moins au moins ça 14,3 donc le match est
déjà terminée mais auquel et bullet qui
vont enchaîner car ils ont le sourire ça
fait plaisir
oui moment ils se sont un peu amusé quoi
et aussi les nouveaux civray annonce a
fait ça fait du bien
bon allez je renvoie la petite pub avant
avec ce insurmontable aller là bas le
petit je pense que la pub choses comme
ça peut faire mal au biogaz je pense que
eux ils peuvent perdre 2010 ouvert sur
la pub des qui a pris d'enjeu en fait
ils ont premières pages et tout mais
sinon il y aurait pas grand monde mais
ils ont gagné des viewer depuis que le
match est fini j'ai vu à chaska mais en
anglais c'est terrible ils sont seize
mille mais bon première page en anglais
c'est après repas de chasse comme
première page en anglais et à 12000
personnes en tout des là c'est énorme
mais en vrai c'est un peu le problème
des premières pages et machin ou quoi
c'est que tu sais pas vraiment ce qui
est organique après ouais c'est pas
vraiment ce qui plaît aux qui paie le
bas parce que toi c'est comme nous on a
été six mille mai mais oui en fait on
aurait mis un écran noir il y aurait eu
6000 personnes aussi plus ou moins donc
ca
c'est un peu c'est un peu difficile je
pense qu'on était dans les 1800 2000 en
fait comme hier en réalité ouais c'est
ça voilà c'est comme ça
bon allez reste plus que que les 30
dernières minutes
là la bonne petite pause histoire d'être
bien sûr qu'il soit reposer quand même
très important c'est s'il vient de ce
que ça reparte de mon envie c'est
qu'avec mon question entend pas du tout
besoin de mon ordi mais je sais
différents bruit d'enfer mais moi j'ai
affirmé mon hôte hba qui sauva je
réponds pas c'est terrible à la lâcher
et essayer parce que il répond peut-être
plus ou plus facilement aux patrons non
non il y pas les messages ça je vois
quand il est là il n'y pas sur wat ap
les messages sont lus et
je lui envoie un renard l'asie arena moi
je sais que lui envoyer 200 g
ah non les gorilles
[Musique]
sinon ce cap canaveral au départ de la
fusée saturn 5 à la houille à la non il
n'y pas aidé aujourd'hui à 18h25 il peut
être ancien ce temps peut être aussi
parié regarder et regarder le match
depuis un moment
y a pas d'heure pour faire la sieste
toutes les heures sont bonnes pour faire
la sieste quand cet art comme ça après
je dors plus la nuit voilà
il s'est endormi devant l'écran ce
possible un gros match pour s'endormir
ouais c'est terrible parce que ouais je
pense que il voulait voir un match un
peu sympa et tout est-il mandat
moi j'étais sûr j'étais plus ou moins
sûr du scénario 1 bat wang n'a pas eu
tort à une heure où ça joue et puis
ensuite puis ensuite c'était trop dur
[Musique]
c'est trop dur trop difficile
pour le joueur pour le joueur iranien
mais wayne et en plus c'est ça qui est
terrible c'est se dire que man u snap
agents un très bon niveau alors que sur
certaines parties et je vous sur
certaines séquences mais de manière
générale de façon beaucoup trop
irrégulière sporadiques
voilà pour pouvoir prétendre à quelque
chose dans cette compétition si je comme
ça tout le temps
il ya trop d'écarts cette compet affaire
est quasiment la limiter à moins de
joueurs de tous et non mais aussi 7,7 ou
pas faire de qualif comme ça où prendre
quatorze joueurs d'office et que deux
qualifiés ou quoi mais tu peux faut
mettre des gens sérieux
il t'a répondu pâquis non je te voyais
sourire je sais pas qui quoi là cet état
aïe aïe aïe baky sauvage
oui nous alors il faudrait mettre
travaille vraiment peu qualifié m aime
parce que tu as même un cariat qui nous
quoi contre magnus il se prend pas une
telle la whey battant on a des joueurs
qui sont pas dans la compétition qui
prendrai pas un tel tarif
ouais mais après comme ils ont voulu
faire la pub des speechs est ce qu il
fallait pour cela des titles du coup ça
a favorisé les joueurs qui les jouets
les plus souvent et je pense que non
mais c'est vrai aussi mais pas cher en
fait tu peux pas tout faire tu peux
avoir le formateur tu peux pas faim il
faut prendre des décisions c'est cher
c'est ok si tu veux ça du couffo les
salles fin c'est juste que là il ya ya
ya ya
puis c'est pas la première année c'est
la quatrième année que c'est comme ça ou
cinquième
en moins de six minutes c'est le
meilleur joueur du monde les champions
du monde 1 ah oui bien sûr c'est
quelqu'un que je suis parti à deux et
demi deux et demi attend qu'il ya des
nids demi donc en fait c'est qu enfin il
en a mis 11 d'affilée du coup on s'est
assis là c'est dur 11-0 assez dur bah
c'est dur de se dire que là les
poubelles que les joueurs du bar quoi
agacer me fait même même ça se passe
bien que tu gagnes tout a quand même
perdu c'est quand même
ouais ouais c'est terrible pour parra
mais en plus à la pause comme on invita
qu'une envie c'est de reprendre le jeu
hein et d'en finir
ouais mais c'est pour ça que j'aimais
bien les deathmatch à l'époque où l'at
elle est vraiment zéro pause chiffres
incitent à le droit d'aller aux
toilettes
une fois dans le match ah mais le match
était bon ça et je crois que là encore
tu sais si les joueurs étaient d'accord
sinon tu te faisais sur ton temps de jeu
mais c'est bien oui bon les deathmatch
c'était sympa oui il y avait eu des
beaux matches
ah oui je m'en rappelle même y avait
andré qui ne contrôlait que j'avais
regardé je le rappelle était un super
match
ouais bah oui après le thé star des
prolongations pour être bien sûr mais
peut être qu'il va bien gérée par am
avec toutes celles qu'il a dû manger ou
la salle cette blague
oui c'était c'était involontaire c'est m
abbas était volontaire salle ça j'ai
créé une réponse du bâti sauvage mais
n'en ont pas le maquis servage
bon allez 7 pour reprendre les vedettes
qu'on ait quelque chose à raconter
c'est terrible et mon soir au gatt n'y a
pas tant pour un 11 0 n'ont normalement
ces neuf parties déjà c'est beaucoup
c'est 8-9-10 vraiment on m'a fait
combien avec sarine
parce qu'il y avait 10 6 et ça finit à
ses ennemis ans et demi du coup il ya eu
beaucoup de parties en fait ouais mais
bon t'as pas vu la pendule t'as rien
fait aussi oui combien il partit
d'anglet
parce que papa optimisée du tout en
avantageant fait non
papa du tout optimisé on attend on a eu
dix on a eu dix et on n'a pas optimiser
la dystonie c'est vraiment c cnet déjà
un peu optimistes disent quand ça se
passe vraiment bien 11
bah oui c'est beaucoup parce qu'avec la
cadence une puce une ya un peu de lag
une seconde d'un crémant 30 où sa fille
jane minutes pas trois minutes par
partie c'est le minimum si ça pousse un
peu bien sûr il dit pas si je crois cinq
ennemis katrina repart enfin voilà enfin
ça repart allait du coup si l'on gagne
si j'en gagne une au moins on est bien
sûr alors attends il ya aussi la
question est-ce qu'il va gagner la
cadence bullet parce que s'ils gagnent
que de cadence sur trois
ça remet tout en cause et oui bah oui
parce qu'en plus à l'époque les
deathmatch je crois que justement les
price money était pas par rapport au
score global mais par rapport au fait
que tu gagnes décadence ou pas mais oui
non mais c'est le deathmatch était
beaucoup mieux ouais et puis en plus tu
avais des matches un peu marrant où il
devait y avoir un genre de lille devrait
pas dépasser l'objectif de qualification
et du coup ça en prochainement les
comportements seul ouais et puis c'était
cet effet pour être des matches serrés
où on n'était pas bien sûr justement de
qui était pas là donc c'était toujours
des matchs et qui devrait non c'était
vraiment bien c'est juste fait ce
travail car six heures vous savez faire
six heures ah oui c'est encore mieux
l'arrêt ce qui va le maté non il va pas
maté aller victoire de parole je tente
encore le pronom le pronom et qui va pas
se réaliser avec des six
d si c'est pourquoi pour pousser 4 et
surtout ici si tu prends c'est celle qui
joue qui est des cinq étaient pas mal
parce que mine de rien tu as ouvert
beaucoup de lille là avec des pions kg 4
c'est bien joué je tape y en a eu cinq
en ligne de mire je peux pas jouer et on
prend des synthés hacker prend les six
claques et prom 5 afrique détroit bien
jouer ouais on voit parle il est pas mal
en boulettes
il trouve des bons coups au foot est roi
c'est un très bon coup total prend le 5e
cette partie va le gagner avec a laissé
le retour de parra les vous allez mon
petit parham de 400 rien à [ __ ] même
fou prendre qu'à toi
il va nous faire quoi magnus pub qui
décide
ouais mais foutez 3 simplement puis tout
réussissait un mandat me projet quatre
tours aussi c'est une boucherie
c'est un massacre ce match c'était ça
dans chaque partie en fait ouais c'est
cool là qui gagnent un peu le cas et qui
va revenir en recettes
ouais après ces petits bouts latin c'est
pas terminé mais et voilà il magnifie à
3296 en doublettes qui va devoir cracher
un petit va passer à la caisse important
battant il n'a pas encore perdu un mois
celle là elle est très dur quand même
parce que le roi blanc il est bien et
qu'il est bien sûr la dame 9,6 et mat
moi je trouve qu'il a quand même failli
complètement perdant 1 mais je leur
parle il a quand même résisté très
longtemps
ah oui bien sûr mais bah ça c'est une de
ses forces un tour 3 c'est bien joué et
ça laisse à faire un point ta meuf 7
gailly aussi aller encore enfin un point
hyper 134 points bim enfin enfin un
pronostic qui passe bon allez ça fait ça
fait un point par hamla qui reprend le
sourire il n'en reste plus que aller si
l'on gagne encore 10 d'affilée il a
peut-être une chance maxime alors il va
falloir gagner les dix ans alors je me
dis tu
condé qu'il en perd une là c'est
vraiment d'experts 10 secondes sur 10
d'agouazi hyper hyper toutes ses chances
non mais c'est vrai que le lag autant ça
ça aurait pas à changer le fait que
magnus se qualifie un mais bien sûr que
non mais ça ça tue une machette ouais ça
doit être parce que sinon on aurait pu
avoir encore un truc un peu plus serré
et puis peut-être cinq points d'écart
quand on arrive aux boulettes et puis
bon bah voilà au moins ça a donné un
match sympa la bombe
[Musique]
on a perdu un peu l'intérêt quoi bon
alors est ce que est ce que par am
penser qu'un français 4 c'est fou
d'avoir jamais pensé 4 après il n'a pas
forcément une mauvaise position mais
cette finale est peut être très très
délicat
adam prend 1,2 à ce c'est un mal joué
mais c'est ça il a des seins perla danan
cette série ce que j'aime bien dans bay
3 2 tours à trois voix près d'être ans
et quatre tours prend même la princesse
à la mélasse et prend des 5 ou c'est
très sain pour ces deux mais ça c'est
fini
c'était mieux de jeu des français 4
prend b3 qui est trempé 3 et de jouer à
tenter un truc là mais là c'est fini
fini
sur la prise pour prince is hell et du
port a misé heim en battant 7 6 ça c'est
le coup de gosse mais voilà la semaine
j'ai officiellement fin non c'était déjà
terminée il ya dix ans d'écart quand
même on va dire qu'il y avait une chance
sur un milliard que ça revienne
ouais amelia baky qui écrit ha ha ha
temps j'ai écrit ça joue encore à tanger
créa baky sage ou encore plus c'est plus
on joue plus +11 y aurait une puissance
pour manu ce terrible là l'enjeu aussi
c'est de voir si ce marché seule raison
samedi cette île annoncé je crois ou 22
émis 7 et nuit donc quinze points
d'écart
là il y en a onze là bas et je crois
qu'ils qui va se présenter c'est la
bonne nouvelle
ah voilà à temps c'est pas fait encore
ok acquis à leur juste valeur jeudi à
21h50
ouais déjà parce que nous on va couper
de façon comment ça finit jeu mais la
petite un 3 oui c'est paris qui va se
présenter alors là les amis j'ai envie
de dire vivement le match nice quand
même pas qui ça va être très important
de regarder à
voilà une bonne nouvelle un bac qui
sauvage qui se présentent à le pâquier
toujours plus plus intéressant quand il
est sauvage soissons oui
est-ce que je vais commenter tout
l'esprit m'a juste chattaoui quand même
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr ça va faire
combien alors attends ça va faire
combien d'heures de live je préfère pas
savoir j'avais calculé pour le speech et
ignorent c'est impressionnant ayala
l'efficace femina aussi j'ai fait deux
saisons et 2,1 en plus comme je dis
toujours c'est vraiment je suis le
premier le plus déçu parce que moi de
battre j'aime bien les échecs du tout ce
que je stream
j'adore oui et du coup en fait à chaque
fois je trace ici le sait on est
tellement pas loin d'avoir un truc qui
fasse vraiment kiffé c'est ça qu'il
fallait en fait parce que ça pourrait
être vraiment bien
ouais donc la wii donc on est seize donc
il ya eu 8 ya quinze matches forcément l
x 15 matches et 15 matches
ouais 60 heures ouais c'est à chaque
fois c'est le tarif c'est 60 heures de
féminin 60 heures juniors sur la senteur
de 180 ouais mais je crois que j'ignore
quand le match était officiellement
terminée du touvet permettre de lâcher
deux alors oui mais uniquement parce
qu'il y avait un autre événement pendant
j'avais le droit parce qu'il y avait une
960 pendant et que tu jouer donc j'ai
dit ah oui c'était fini voulait partir
et il y avait eu un autre truc je sais
plus lequel qui avait fait pareil
peut-être un teint maso qui devait venir
ou une master class ou un truc comme ça
qui était prévenu avant le étaient
prévus avant
la raison c'est parce que j'avais dit il
ya déjà quelque chose d'autre dans le
calendrier qui est plus intéressant et
mais merci non c'était mort elle se
plaint pas il pourrait doubler le nombre
de matches en faisant le système du
loser bracket
ah oui ce serait beau belle idée oui à
exceptionnel
oh ça mérite un mail à rennes oc vérité
et le mail e mail est méritée cette pop
aussi l'afrique et à l'idée de génie
voilà après ouais en tout cas je retiens
le siège que tu m'a tendu un proposant
commenter ce match terrible piège dans
lequel je suis tombé à tous les jours
écoute pour te dire vrai g on a écrit
pour me dire ou es ce serait vraiment
bien que maxime commenter un match de
speechless cette année et tous et moi
j'étais pour te faire commenté cheyrou
déjà fait de ses gaffes
voilà donc j'avais dit tiens il affirme
déjà fait 2 cf yerodia machin peut-être
devenir français et tout ça est beau
match avec maxime sinon non beaucoup
plus intéressant par un magnus d'accord
objets non on repasse en voilà avec
paraître cela du couvent et du coup
scénic et scénic
non c'est panique cc c'est vrai mais ça
doit être ni quoi je pense c'est le
tchèque
non j'étais c'était sam qui m'a écrit ça
mais ça devait s'il veut remonter plus
haut donc ça doit pas être lui mais met
du coup dans moi je t'avais me de base
je t'avais mise sur fil rouge à feydeau
cfdt dommage de commenter ce match là
ben oui c'est très dommage mais en fait
je sais pas pourquoi ils sont hypnotisés
par le fait d'avoir un gros joueur jarry
pense aussi que naka martirossian ça va
être le lot de gros matches ouais alors
qu'en fait bas ben alors peut-être si
par exemple sur les audiences de chaises
comme évidemment c'est bien d'avoir mal
agi mais sur chaise com fr ça va rien
changer
norman ou ce qui change en vrai c'est
surtout toi voilà way magnus ça change
un peu ou quoi mais tu as quand même
envie même magnus ça te fait un buzz de
10% tu préfère avoir des gens chaud
pendant quatre heures que des gens chaud
pendant une heure
vous voyez bien sûr après martirossian
sait jamais et contemporain petit c'est
moulian ça peu à moi j'espère une
victoire 2
de martirossian le drapeau de l'arménie
sera sorti ça c'est sûr ça sera oui
ah oui je te confirme que là on se sait
qu'il supportait dans un match comme ça
ah bah oui largement
je pense d'ailleurs que tu seras assez
chaud pendant le match si jamais se
passe pas trop mal mais bon j'y crois
pas trop
non malheureusement je crois que ça va
être difficile parce que c'est un
minaret
s'il n'a qu'à joue comme au championnat
us oui possible éprouver la cimade au
championnat us s'est passé quoi
aucune idée après c'est un niveau qui me
semble plus cohérent par rapport au fait
qu'il arrêtait de jouer
professionnellement depuis longtemps
même si il mais il doit faire mieux que
ça mais ça me paraissait pas des gens
que c'est logique d'avoir des hauts et
des bas comme d'habitude il avait que
des eaux quoi donc c'est un voilà donc
ça me paraît cohérent pour quelqu'un en
pré retraite de de faire des très gros
tournant en temps puis détournant raté
d'autres voient les parents qui va
peut-être gagner une deuxième partie oui
j'avais reçu un t aimes tu cours tu as
pas la prise et g4 a gagné une pièce en
effet voilà c'est ça mon par am c'est
génial martirossian le choix entre
perdre contre hikaru se faire battre par
thiès comme cas pas c'est pas fou je
crois que c'est pas faux et je sais pas
et lui a été là que le martyre au ciel a
le choix entre perdre à wanaka ousfar
ban duchess chrome os et naga qui a dit
sur son style qui se sentait plus fort
que jamais notamment au vu de ces
résultats avec mes muses dernièrement
homme charmant il incarna berges été
surpris hier de son stream sponso j'ai
pas vu il a été il a fait un strip
sponso par baden gamme hier
ah ça j'avais jamais vu encore j'ai été
très surpris gt gt sur le cucquois as
pop art by dane a bah oui c'est
exceptionnel sages avaient marre encore
ils paient ce que si ça c'est pas de la
physique tu peux décider
ah non je vais écrire c'était bien mais
tu peux décider parce que bon bah
forcément une des contraintes etc mais
qui peut décider de soutenir la campagne
de bill dann mais je faire payer pour ça
c'est un peu spécial
ah oui j'étais étonné en fait de bas je
pensais qu'il y avait juste fait un
stream en mode soutien by donnent bon
déjà sa mort est sûre après je sais que
je suis et c'est autorisé mais oui non
autorisée meyers et ses salles spéciales
quand même bord oui oui je sais je crois
qu'il ya eu 8 milliards de dollars qui
ont été investis en publicité dans la
campagne
hallucinant quand tu y penses ah oui non
c'était on est bien sûr qu'ils ont un
chiffre est assez d'argent pour y
appliquer partout 6 allers et la type
dash 8 milliards j'étais pas loin je
savais que c'était huit séances mais ça
paraît tout aussi exceptionnel synac a
accepté cette feuille de liteon sait
quand même qu'il le soutien oui oui non
mais non mais qu'il le soutienne oui
mais bon c'est pas un concept mais enfin
tu peux tu peux le faire payer pour
plaindre que tu fais du versement de sow
pour plein de trucs mais bon moi je
trouve ça sert à quoi ça ne viendrait
jamais à l'esprit en admettant que je
sois politiser ce que je suis pas
forcément faire payer pour pour un
meeting politique
enfin peu importe bof
après c'est un autre pays c'est notre
mentalité bien sûr c'est que je fais
c'est normal mais non jugé télé c'est
pas pour ça que c'est recommande non
plus qu'on pour le coup c'est vraiment
pas un truc que j'en prends perdu à
faire plein de trucs que je vends cause
yacine et surtout surtout pas cette
culture de l'argent
ok c'est malsain non juste moi ça m'a
surpris parce que je pensais que c'est
un live comme ça et puis et puis en plus
il se faisait un peu sur twitter il
s'est fait tacler par plein de gens qui
étaient pro trompé tous faim quant à une
grosse connu comme ça c'est pas
forcément non plus une bonne idée de de
prendre parti pour quelqu'un ou
quelqu'un d'autre quoi et pas ravir fait
porte il a atteint sur le piano 5 qui va
tomber il ya peut-être quelques
pronostics et prince is ok même idée
ouais ça marche mais un quelconque
attaque 17
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe coup dur coup dur
tour à tour s'est vite en plus fous des
lecteurs prandelli pour prendre le set
donc je défends bien résistant mais je
me fais pas payer pour défendre notre
dictature du pakistan en même temps je
suis et choux gras des 1 forcément ça je
n'en vois la voie juste samassa massa
m'a surpris mais après oui c'est juste
le truc qui marque qui m'a surpris y
aurait donc mais disent officiellement
il ne se fait pas payer pour soutenir le
pakistan est important
donc non mais en tout cas ça va changer
ce qui aurait dansé sur les bonne came
il reste combien de thoiry il reste
douze minutes on en voit le bout
oui c'était beau il car il avait aussi
proposé par contre j'ai une question
soit que match et termine et envoie une
bonne petite pub avant de quitter le
live
oui bien sûr important mais il est
proposé de faire une simultanée aussi
dans le cadre de la campagne de baden à
obama par nature quand même ce côté mais
ça c'est très américain quoi c'est
différent mais toujours le côté quand
même de vouloir faire du surtout quoi
oui c'est c'est un côté qu'on a pas en
france après oui j'ai vu que lui aussi a
fait un bond girl alors après je sais
pas si l appétit pour faire partie de ce
manga
tu vois par exemple je pense que là pour
le coup non mais je me trompe peut-être
vrai nom ça a marché avec toasts et il
faut qu'ils man city s'est fait huer par
pareil aussi grand moment kg 4 aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe
et puis entre en jeu deux intermédiaires
peut être marrant aussi pour sortir et
pranger 5e large et aux mails et oran
d'élite intermédiaire ah oui voilà
là on est bien sûr que ça va faire 14
points d'avance donc du coup on n'est
pas loin des 15 et il reste gaz 10
minutes
ah là là donc ça peut se finir par un 3
2 pour le 22 sept
mais je crois que c'était 22 et demi cet
ennemi même plus 14
et toi tu as des sponsors maxime d'heure
ça permettrait de leur faire de la pub
au passage ou pas au web alors je suis
content s'enlise et puis depuis dix ans
par colis qui une boîte de l'immobilier
basse et gilbert taser qui est passionné
d'échecs à fond qui a notamment fondé le
pôle excellence qui permet d'entraîner
les meilleurs les jeunes français les
plus prometteurs
donc dans marquant brillamment outils il
ya une marque de matériel et puis il y
en a d'autres
il est bas vous avez tous ceux qui sont
dans cette catégorie d'âge un poil moins
fort mais quand même un prometteur voilà
ça je crois que c'est un rizaï 1 2 par
am voilà et puis puis plus récemment la
iliad vivendi qui me soutient dans
quatre ans coule voilà ouais c'est cool
des bonnes nouvelles on espère dans un
ennemi macron je ne fais pas empêché
troll j'étais obligé a déjà dit ma
grande tu as dit pâtir mélenchon le pen
non j'ai troll mais je suis resté dans
le la mais je pense que femme je suis me
vois bien sûr ça peut changer mais je ne
vois pas apporté un soutien direct à
quelques politiques que ce soir au t1
c'est à dire m c'est terrible pauvres si
j'étais obligé de troll
ah ouais
vous avez la parole qu'il a mise clic
ouais attend ça veut pas ça veut pas
dire que le match avait commencé sur un
mystique de magnus
elle a prêté 3 à 6 la dame qui enfermés
s'il voit la cdjp en laye et le 4 way en
lice à prendre pions blancs et peut-être
et c'est 2 à 6 assists d'abord à we
insist une chasse de la diagonale et uhf
et puis on prend après les bienvenus
ouais même idée d'ailleurs j'aurais dit
à 6 plus précis nationale il ya
peut-être dmb 4 avec bon ça va quand
même aller mais c'est moins gagnants qui
vont mais moins sûr que c'est gagné
j'avais une chance
attend il reste combien de temps à
souffrir après barça la rs6 mise 44 il
est parti il va perdre toutes les
cadences un oui terrible
frei ni mox bien sûr il faudrait que les
brutes bien sûr c'est important
un constat que tomber 4o à ay ay ay
aller
non là c'est tombé tard en france
atterrit à ça je peux très bien vivre
après ça peut se comprendre
oh oui
j'aimerais tellement faire une fois les
interviews en anglais demandé ryori
totalement épique comme question e
défense en pro de châssis d'heure le
pronostic c'est pas du tout annoncer
quoi ça se peut qu'il y en ait plus aie
aie aie aie c'est terrible ça c'est
dommage en interview d'après match quand
on gage était règles et quand même on a
on a envie de voir l'arménie continue à
gagner cette compétition voilà je crois
qu'ils pourront plus rejoué
malheureusement à la sympathie
souhaitait pas ils ont pas été
shadowbane ils ont été bannis
la puce 16 tu as comme quoi l'algorithme
harris était quand même pas trop trompé
ouais bah ouais bah après une fin si
pour moi si parce que le langage a fait
très très mal sur trop début du match
oui c'est vrai aussi elle a clairement
car la scène joue pour les lots non en
france du poids ce qui l'obligé de jouer
ou alors ils vont se taper un petit
match en 100 boulettes après il ya qui
est tombé 5 je pense vous êtes très mal
la parra milliers plus du tout c'est
génial car il date des tempos
complètement craqué dans la tête par
c'est normal maugendre traqué depuis
bien longtemps également jeu français
cracker le français incapable d'être
mobilisés s'ils émanaient de 8 points
dans un match c'est terrible
prends tellement cher mais tellement
cher francis laporte prend 17 ans
prendrait cet effort est de 3,5 après il
y avait rien de mal à jouer simple dans
cette position phare et fils pour le
troll moins fort mais plus drôle c'est
plus le moment de troller tout va si
cela pour bien trop attirer ce pro 1
une petite baisse un plat qui va tomber
je le connais montmagny et saint laurent
je le pourrai rentrer dans sa tête en
cas de match c'est bon la dame 17
beachvolley
adam détroit j'avais vu ça les sept
n'avaient pas eu encore plus sympa parce
que ça a évité ce truc là j'avais vu
jusque là
après j'ai dit que ça pouvait être sûre
mais où il ya plus rien j'avais eu peur
d'un sacrifice ou d'un truc pareil
bon c'est peut-être la dernière mon max
20 et 21 à 5 c'est peut-être un peu
maintenant je sais pas si horrible
bosses et 22 secondes à 5
ouais ça fait 8 2 dans le bullet ben nan
mais c'était sûr c'était sûr que ça
enchaînerez par ama qui voit le l'écart
qui le sépare balle assez terrible hein
même les mêmes les scandinaves à la con
elle se passe très mal
il est déjà moins bien je pense par
scandinave à la con il s'use et moi
monsieur l'inspecteur 13 heures oui mais
ces screens mt 6 oui bien sûr j'ai eu
raison d'eux
l'appellation était juste ouais les
scandinaves la fiom 36 pourquoi pas pour
essayer de gagner la dernière partie
comme ça il pourra dire mais au tennis
s'engueulent la dernière partie en
amoureux de continuer le match forcément
forcément pourquoi il joue abbas a oui
c'est du rand est ce que vraiment là
pour le coup il ya que magnus et n'a
qu'à qu'ils sont capables de faire ça
c'est de déchirer complètement un mec
moi j'en suis incapable je n'ai pas
cette capacité à faire aussi mal ça peut
être pas l'envi nom aussi ça joue aussi
oui mais mais de toute façon même si
j'en avais envie
à un moment je me déconcentre c'est sûr
là il s'était concentré un moment mais
bon pas longtemps quand même à il a
maintenant on a une dernière on a une
berder par am qui en a qui veut pas
arrêter je vais encore en rejouer une à
ça peut finir en perte est ça c'est
génial ça fait sur un petit peu ridicule
quoi oui mais tu sais ce qu'ils auraient
dû faire là pour trois le format je sais
ils font la partie la plus longue
possible donc toujours 49 cook et tu
joues un couple pion à oui je crois que
ça peut faire 5800 coup mais tu quoi une
seconde d'un crémant parcours ça fait
très mal
sarah ruhl 5800 déjà ces deux heures oui
oui ça fait mal car ça peut faire une
partie de 4 heures je pense ça peut
faire tellement mal ouais
actuel avec les meilleures idées ray
c'est sage en vue d'organiser le troll
si tu joues contre manu son vrai je suis
sûr qu'il serait capable d'accepter
lebron peut-être aussi les feux de forêt
que tu as un anichois un truc comme ça
pour être bien sûr ah ah oui à nicheurs
garanich c'est sûr ah oui c'est sûr on
ferme le format à nice france est même
capable de faire ça dans le 5 puis
scindant le 3 + 5 dans le 1 + 5 ans elle
est trois fois combien
non
en
ouais euh pensez à mathieu qui est
complètement sueur de leurs ancêtres
partis
il peut dire que c'est théorique mais tu
vas tout analysé maintenant y aura une
master class la semaine prochaine de
suivre ici je le vis bien mais ça ce
serait un prof fantastique à faire je
t'en prie je viens d'avoir mis 17 mois
sari n'y aurait pas accepté dans un truc
pareil non bien sûr que non mais
fantastique
ben ali des vrais ouais j'avais la
farine actifs les losers ce bon après le
danger c'est que c'est que l'on se fasse
troll parce que à cause des trois fois
la même position
voilà c'est quand tu bouges pas les
pions c'est difficile d'éviter les trois
fois la même présent si vous faites une
partie de 2 800 900 coup c'est déjà beau
ah oui non mais faut faire une avec tu
mets un carré y en a 3 puis après tu
bouges ton cavaliers pas mal de fois
puis tu refais cavaliers tu fais khalid
sekkat futur boulot de cavaliers en fait
ça il faut toucher un cavalier assad et
rodrigue complètement c'est parce qu'ils
feraient dans ce cas je sais pas mais
généralement les américains ils sont
hyper fort pour ça pour pas être
décontenancé pour plus volés ou quoi
ouais mais pour des trois premières
minutes oui mais là c'est une partie tu
peut durer plus dinars type le faire
tout un segment
enfin en théorie c'est une partie qui
peut durer quatre heures non mais c'est
extraordinaire si vous faites ça à
chaque fois que ce serait le plus beau
match et une dernière pour magnus
ouais voilà bon bah c'est terminé
ce match est terminé on est on est assez
sûr quand même de piété de l'énergie
dans ce match toujours trop court un
autre corps mais elles vont 19 points
d'écart c'est ouais on semble rentrer
dans un truc voilà on peut se dire que
le joueur qui était probablement plus
fort l'emporté
voilà après c'est quand même resté serré
jusqu'au bout et puis il ya les
circonstances extérieures aussi qu'ils
ont joué donc je pense qu'il faut
rejouer le match en voyant match retour
pour moi voilà match retour alors je
vais envoyer un raid
et puis du coup on va repartir avec baky
qui va arriver dans une quinzaine de
minutes donc à tout les gars à tout
maxime merci d'avoir commenté avec moi
j'imagine que tu as trop posé un petit
peu comme moi un petit peu ouais je n'ai
que d'aller en fatigue et on se retrouve
dans quelques quelques secondes à tout
les gars merci max de tout ça